[Music]
so first of all thank you for bringing
us freakin Portland weather great storm
here in LA today what's going on has not
stopped raining there was lightning
storms last night it was crazy did you
get in this morning or not it was a very
bumpy ride yeah this morning from San
Jose so super wet out here today very
Oregon and then right after you have
Jesse Thomas coming in so a lot of
Oregon energy exactly the vibes coming
in today right get ready
super excited to talk to you this is
your third time on the podcast it's an
honor I can't every time you go knock
out some crazy thing tell me about it
but uh what's what's interesting I was
reflecting on our relationship a little
bit I mean we I think you you emailed me
or reached out to me like years ago
maybe when we were living in Kauai
because your dad has a farm there yeah
he tried to connect at that point when
you were still racing triathlon exactly
I think it was your first podcast is
from Kauai that's right exactly so right
in that same moment yeah my dad has
lived on Kauai for almost 20 years now
he's an organic farmer out there in
Kilauea and I got made aware of you by a
friend of mine KC McGraw who was a guy I
think like wrote a couple segments of
the epic 5 maybe with use like he was my
dad's first woofer on his organic farm
moved out for a surf trip from Florida
and ended up he's still living there
married my next-door neighbor and
they've got a kid who was like why so he
got bit by the bug but yeah I think
that's how I got first nerd you see what
with that 2010 alone II know it was uh
that was 2012 25 ok 2012 and then yeah I
was racing track alone professionally at
that point and I think we we did we
connected over Twitter something like
that but never never hooked up though
yeah exactly but we did hook up in New
York City
yes like was that like two months ago or
something like that
you're staying in the same hotel you
would literally it was like two days
after you completed this journey and you
went straight to New York City like I
think you had your sled with you even
been home yet and we were texting like
hey I see you in your New York I'm in
New York let's let's try to get together
I'm like great I'm bounced around pretty
busy but where are you in the city we
both texted each
the same address sitting in the same
pose away from each other yeah and then
we ran into each other in the elevator
my favorite part of this story is I was
I was going out to some fancy dinner and
I was all dressed up in a blazer and
then I come out of the elevator and
there you are in like a nice coat like
like you know good Yale grad and I was
like where are you going and you're
going you're on your way to CNN which
our hotel was literally two blocks away
from and I was like oh great you can
just walk down the street that's awesome
and I was like I was like yeah but they
they sent a car because they're worried
that if it got a little snowy I couldn't
handle it but yeah to you and I couple
West Coast guys trying to call fancy for
the New York City folks I know that's a
rare occasion
yes very rare and you've just been on a
tear you're in like a new city every
single day if you watch your Instagram
stories it has been non-stop since
you've been back yeah it's been it's
been a blessing but it's funny when I
saw you in New York I got back from
Antarctica on January 3rd spent a few
days Jenna came down and met me down
there of course my lovely wife and
business partner and she came and met me
down there and we took a couple days in
Chile before going back but she was like
hey we're not flying back to the
Portland actually back home we need you
in New York City to be on the Today Show
stuff going from 54 days alone to Tenten
an article with nobody else to the
bright lights of New York State I was a
little bit jarring but like I said it's
been a blessing and I'm really you know
humbled by all the press and media
attention and a crazy attention it's
been amazing
Adam Skolnick did an unbelievable job of
chronicling you know this from day one
absolutely everybody riveted I mean
there was just piece after piece after
piece in the New York Times
yeah it was incredible yeah and that the
atom connection actually originally
comes to via you because right when he
wrote that article about you doing oh
tillow Otello or however he pronounced
that he had reached out or you had
reached out to me to see how he wants to
interview a couple people been on the
podcast and him and I became friends
from rare and he did such an
extraordinary job with the New York
Times pieces it was incredible to see
and it was regionally supposed to be one
or two pieces but I guess they liked it
so much
they ended up doing seven or eight or
something like that and building this
whole tracker around it I didn't get to
see all this in real time of course but
what's happening kind of as I back here
when I was out on the ice not only was
the coverage riveting they did an
incredible job of displaying it
graphically in a very artistic way that
was immersive that was very cool
yeah so here you are man the last time
we spoke you had just completed the
explorers grand slam setting the world
record on that like you just go from one
thing to the next and then right before
this Antarctica expedition you did fit
the 50 tallest summits in the in the
United States yes in like 21 days 21
days 50 points I tried to get you to
come out and I know you're like at least
come and do this one dude it'll be a
Vlad is a one of my big regrets
yeah doing that yeah that was it was a
good time yeah that that journey was a
wild one you know for me you know
creating these projects you know setting
these World Records is kind of you know
a fun piece of this but it's been fun to
really start to think of myself less as
an athlete and more of as an artist and
as I create these projects you know what
sort of positivity and vibration I can
send inspiration out into the world and
also how can I get people to participate
and collaborate with them the Antarctica
project being alone in Antarctica of
course didn't in person have a lot of
collaboration potential but the 50
highpoints was a blast with that project
Jen and I kind of created this concept
that we called the Forrest Gump effect
and so we invited anyone else I was
racing across the United States to come
out and join us climb a mountain with us
you know climb a peak of course on the
East Coast some of these are little like
hills in Florida it's a 325 foot you
know hill on this side of the road but
we had a whole bunch of teachers come
join us out there school kids on various
paths and so that project was so fun to
see all 50 states in that period of time
but also meet all these incredible
people and all these different locations
was really really fun but to do it in 21
days I mean I can understand 50 days but
21 days you're doing at least two a day
yes yeah gistic Lee that must have been
super tricky yeah Jenna is a logistic
mastermind that's for sure
but yeah the way that project work is
basically the world-record clock starts
ticking when you reach the summit of the
first peak and so in this case
Denali was very first because of course
that's long as to get up so went out
there with a climbing part and a really
good friend of mine a guy main doctor
John Curtis ski out of Colorado so he
climbed that peak with me and we
strapped skis on from the summit and got
back down as quickly as we could so we
literally summited Denali got our skis
packed up our camp skied all the way
back down to the little Airport and at
my airport but a landing strip out there
and a bush plane picks us up flies us
back to Anchorage John stays there and
packs up our stuff but I get in a car
and drive straight down to the Anchorage
Airport and Alaska is like closing there
the airport door is closing we get the
last person on the plane that flies it
straight to Hawaii and it just starts
from there so we go Alaska Hawaii fly
back to the mainland United States and
kind of work our way east to west and
have kind of two modes of transport
we've got an RV had this amazing cruise
America RV but we just lived in out of
my whole career there's about five or
six of us filmmaker Jenna my friend
Blake a couple other folks we're there
with us which was amazing and then we
kind of drove our way up and down the
East Coast from place to place but then
also my main sponsors company called
standard process who played a huge role
in Antarctica as well we can talk about
that from the food standpoint but they
let us use they were like hey do you
want to borrow our time machine and I
was like I like time machines what are
we talking like this and they they let
me use the company plane for a few of
the segments so on some of them really
hard to get to places we gotta hop in a
private plane which was very very first
for me I think that probably saves two
or three days off it didn't it didn't
save quite as much time it wasn't like
didn't save like 10 days or something
off it but a few really crucial flight
segments we're huge in there but
basically we did about 10,000 miles on
this RV constant motion so either the
RVs driving I'm sleeping and if we get
there we get to place it 1 o'clock in
the morning 2:00 o'clock more it's like
alright call and get out you gotta go go
climb and it's it's each peak for it
there's a different peak in each state
yes so like what's the peak in Nebraska
yeah like Kansas yes so there's I mean
obviously some of these are these you
know smaller Peaks I think Kansas it was
called a Sun sunflower Mountain Mount
sunflower actually that one was
incredible though we arrived and we
gotten a little bit delayed that day I
was coming from actually so Mount
he got closed we get there the Mount
Whitney and a huge lightning strike had
happened right at the trailhead so I'm
about to climb it my dad actually had
trained it was his sixtieth birthday
that day July 11th of this past year and
he was gonna climb it with me he's been
that's one that I was gonna join you for
exactly exactly and that actually got
got disrupted because of this lightning
strike they're like we're not letting on
in in there right now and I'm on this
world record clock I'm like wait look
what should we do fortunately we
realized we still had to hit Arizona so
we popped over to Arizona that morning
with me and my dad climbed Arizona
Humphreys peak and then he did to get
Nebraska in Kansas before going to
Colorado and so we fly out there we're a
little bit delay we hit Nebraska which
is just a drive up basically take a
quick photo off you know tag the hunt
you know 1000 feet above sea level
whatever and then we get to Kansas at
like 2:00 in the morning at this point
we're thinking no one's gonna join us
for this one obviously we're trying to
get people to join us this Forrest Gump
effect but we're like you know like it's
two o'clock in the morning middle
nowhere in western Kansas it's very
rural it's not nearing the cities and
sure enough we get into this parking lot
and these lights flash and there's this
kid is an incredible guy who had seen on
the Instagram that we were coming out
there was at work that morning and said
sorry to his boss I gotta go do this and
drove eight and a half hours from the
farther side of Kansas to join us at the
top of Mount sunflower and we're just
what like 2008 it's not it's not even a
5 it's like basically a parking lot and
like a little plaque and he gets out of
his cars like oh my god you're here this
is amazing like he was like so psyched
and I was just like you know just
humbled that he was so excited and the
best part I was like he's like dude I've
been sitting here but I didn't have any
food or any water so we had like giving
food and water to him
and I was like so what are you gonna do
you're gonna like just grab a hotel and
then drive back in Warren he's like he's
like no man I got a clock in for work at
8:00 a.m. so he was literally getting
back this car driving all the way back
home and going to work so massive
shout-out to him for joining us out that
was incredible and so when does the
original idea for the Antarctica
expedition pop into your head because
you didn't announce it until super late
yeah yeah so even while we were working
on the 50 high points which was a blast
you know we've been working on
Antarctica kind of in my mind for about
two years at the end of 2016
Jenna and I you know we've kind of built
projects you know really kind of from
nothing there's a little bit more
infrastructure around us these days but
you know when we started out it was just
literally a one-bedroom apartment and a
whiteboard with us some ideas like hey
should we try this it was like we don't
have any sponsors but every marketing
background we know nothing about how to
pull these things together I didn't have
that much background in you know
mountaineering at that point and you
know we kind of just pulled it together
on a shoe screen but that's where these
ideas kind of recreated just the two of
us just I da ting and that one this I
have a whiteboard that says you know the
race across Antarctica and 2016 the
reason that had come to my mind wasn't
just out of nowhere of course you know
going back as far as Ernest Shackleton
in 1914 you know he attempted to do a
traverse of Antarctica with his whole
team and of course that was an ill-fated
expedition but one of the greatest like
adventure stories I in my opinion of all
time where everyone his crew you know
survived incredible leadership
principles but then in the modern era
you know what said this as part as a
world-first it's important to kind of
distinguish which is mmm you know no one
had crossed the landmass of Antarctica
solo unsupported which means no
resupplies of food and then unaided so
not no use of kites or dogs or vehicles
or anything like that but people of
course over the past hundred years have
figured out how to do that you know
using kites and things some really
extraordinary expeditions have happened
but the sort of really pure form of just
man hauling hadn't been accomplished and
in 2015 right at the same time that I
was starting the explorers Grand Slam
World Record in Antarctica as well a guy
named Henry Worsley was attempting this
crossing and so I was just fascinated by
his project following along because I
was in Antarctica for my very first time
doing a much shorter expedition across
the last degree of latitude and climbing
Mount Vinson as part of the explorers
Grand Slam and Henry and I arrived the
South Pole about I don't know at exactly
a few days apart from each other he was
there just before me so I never met him
but was just aware of this kind of
really epic expedition taking place and
unfortunately you know about a month
later 71 days into his expedition he
fell ill and then ultimately passed away
as a result of complications of his
sickness that happened with him out
there which was you know terribly sad
and it also received a lot of media
attention that sort of kind of people
started asking in the media like is this
crossing even possible you know can
humans carry enough you know food
without being resupplied
in the weight of the sleds too heavy and
kind of all these sort of you know
armchair questions you know kind of kept
happening but you know in the zeitgeist
of exploration there was a curiosity
there so the following year or two years
later a guy named Ben Saunders attempted
the project as well a prolific you know
polar explorer out of the UK as well and
he's done some really pioneering stuff a
North Pole South Pole really amazing
expedition somebody I've looked up to
and I thought for sure when he was gonna
attempt I was like oh wow like Ben's
doing this if anyone's gonna do this
project it's gonna be him and Jenna and
I you know had this idea in the back of
her mind to try it but we weren't in
place to do it this year and was just
kind of cheering him along and following
his blog and then sure enough on about
you know day 50 or 51 of his expedition
he arrived at the South Pole and made
the call that he was running too low on
supplies and wasn't going to be able to
complete the full Traverse and so he had
to get picked up at the South Pole which
kind of opened the doorway for me to
give it a shot the following year right
and at what point did you become aware
that that Lewis Rudd was gonna make this
attempt also yeah of course that's uh
you know the big factor here so
Antarctica you know for those who don't
have general context on it which is
pretty much everyone understandably
because it's frozen desolate place in
the bottom of the world
polar bears ya know polar bears even
common misconception as well like we
talked about before but know that you
know there's only one season really
where you can do a crossing of
Antarctica I mean it's the Antarctic
summer basically and then the logistics
are very very limited down there there's
really only you know one company that
services a couple of planes that
supports expeditions and scientific
research and it's a really really
specific set of on a window and so if
you're gonna try this project you
basically need to be down there at the
very beginning of the season with the
same guy who owns like the one plane
drop you off on the edge of the
continent and so Lou Rudd announced that
he was gonna attempt this in March of
this past year I had already been
working on it quietly in the background
but I wasn't super surprised to be
honest to know that somebody else was
going to be attempting this given sort
of the fanfare that this project had
been getting and Lou was an expedition
partner of Henry Worsley on the Reyes
expedition so they were proud at his
expedition yeah right and super I mean
supernova like I said Henry was an
inspiration of mine from afar but I know
actually met him but Lou of course is
you know really involved and they've
done a 68 day expedition together in
Antarctica and her close friends from
the military and all this kind of stuff
and so Lou announced his project which
didn't really change my you know
decisions or tactic in any ways but I
didn't actually publicly know it's my
project as you mentioned until about a
week before leaving for Antarctica even
though I've been working on it for well
over a year right and I would imagine
part of the impetus is looking at these
other people who have attempted it and
had been unsuccessful in thinking like
know what he's done this yeah yeah
absolutely it's a crack right yeah I
mean you know for me I always admired
the you know the pioneering explorers of
yesteryear you know reading Ernest
Shackleton's book or Teddy Roosevelt you
know going floating down you know
through the Amazon or of course Sir
Edmund Hillary being the first to climb
Everest and stuff like this just these
iconic people that you know to me are
still just in this amazing pantheon of
exploration and I kind of felt like wow
I was born too late for this I was born
in 1985
you know we've got you know a lot more
modern technology there satellite
mapping like you know is it you know is
there a difference between exploration
nowadays certainly than it was back then
you know that's ironic yeah sorry go
ahead you know I don't want to interrupt
you but I you know I have this vision of
like a place like the Yale Club in New
York like wood paneled walls like you
know paintings of dogs hunting where
this old adventurers sit and you know
regale people with their stories yes you
know this is Sir Ranulph Fiennes exactly
tradition of explore exactly and for me
like I've just been fascinated by that
for so long and you know even even now
having completed this crossing I don't
necessarily you know put myself right up
beside them in my mind they're still
just my heroes in a different category
but they you know for me I was like wow
like there is this iconic first that
remains undone in Antarctica which is
this solo unsupported unaided Traverse
and so for that reason it was
fascinating to me and again just as a
way of one exploring the own kind of
unlocking the own potential inside my
own body as an athlete an endurance
athlete but also this sort of curiosity
it's one thing you know these other
world records I had said you know being
the fastest person to complete certain
things was unique no one had
ever done it as fast the Seven Summits
explores grandsire the 50 high points
but people have completed those things
and so it was different to step into
this kind of unknown if like wow people
have attempted this and no one has done
it like why like where did they get it
wrong like how can I kind of try to
figure it out better is it even possible
and that's why Jenna and I ultimately
name the project the impossible first
and that this kind of not at you know
not not poking fun and not being cocky
or anything I've actually literally
going like is this possible let's let's
try and find it out and there was no
there was no you know there's a good
possibility in our minds that it wasn't
going to be possible that we would fail
but I wanted to give it my best shot
so being a student of that legacy and
kind of trying to deconstruct you know
these past expeditions was there
something that you identified like oh
here's where they went awry or here's
where I can correct this mistake like
what did you what did you kind of
discern from looking at those past
expeditions to try to figure out what
you would do differently so that you
wouldn't you know befall the same fate
yeah you know one of the things and it's
apropos to be on your podcast talking
about this but really was the nutrition
you know I looked at some of these other
expeditions so there's kind of been this
you know old-school polar explorations
just like get super fat because you're
gonna lose a lot of weight eat a bunch
of cheese and salami and you know
pemmican you know whatever bacon or
whatever frozen bacon you know this kind
of stuff and I've you know as you know I
you know I run a smaller nonprofit that
since you know around inspiring kids to
get outside move their bodies and live
active healthy life really focus on
health and wellness with young people
and just being a product of a father who
is an organic farmer and a mother who's
you know in the natural foods industry
in the Pacific Northwest you know I'm to
have this deep curiosity around whole
food health and nutrition and so I was
like okay I wonder if like you could get
that that's the nutrition piece of this
really right how much of a difference
would that make because it's ultimately
this massive massive math equation where
it's unsupported right so you can't put
any extra things in your sled every
every ounce you put in your sled is
super important and Ben Saunders
unfortunately didn't quite take didn't
quite take enough Henry's worth Lieb
Oddie's you know broke down because
maybe he wasn't getting the right
nutrition and calories I don't know for
sure but that was sort of a question
that I had and so I found this amazing
sponsor this company called standard
process you might be from
with them but the whole food supplement
company out of Wisconsin incredible
operation you know a thousand acre
organic farm vertically-integrated you
know all work with you know
chiropractors and acupuncture I mean
just an incredible you know sort of high
ethic company and I said to them I
presented this idea I said hey I want to
try this and people are calling this
project impossible I mean I think
there's a quote from Wired magazine that
says it's humanly impossible to carry
enough calories to get your body across
Antarctica and I said you know hey I
knew that they're opening this Nutrition
Innovation Center this year in Charlotte
where they basically assembled some of
the top doctors you know food scientists
just really smart people around her food
health and nutrition and it could figure
out could we figure this out and so we
spent a year with them I did you know
several hundred blood tests I was in
their endurance lab you know running vo2
max testing body fat all this kind of
stuff and ultimately the byproduct of
that was to come up with a custom food
solution that would fuel me which was
ultimately all plant-based and it was
whole food it was basically they created
what they called the column bars which
is kind of a funny name you had a chance
to try them right and they're good yeah
yeah they're they're not too bad they're
they're quite good so it's it's it's
basically solving this equation of
trying to pack the most amount of
calories and nutritional density into
the least amount of like net weight that
you're gonna have to pull yes and so
when you underwent all of these studies
the vo2 max and the blood work what was
it that they figured out from your
specific you know genetic makeup or
predisposition that informed how they
came up with that formula so they
started out by doing food sensitivity
testing just to find out where the
inflammatory markers were around food
some of them were obvious to me because
things that I've just known in my past
which is you know like peanuts I just
never really agreed with me super well
what else there was a you know red meat
something I've eaten a lot of throughout
my life I was kind of raised on a more
of pescetarian diet just in general with
way my parents ate as a kid that wasn't
a huge surprise me but then there were
some weird ones it was like ginger and
bad or good bad for me I'm not not like
bad in general but just inflammatory
markers for meaning it's gonna promote
inflammation yeah because your body is
under so much stress
they're even in you know day to day life
probably a little ginger for me is
totally fine
but in this sense we're trying to like
minimize inflammation because my body
was gonna be under so much stress we're
trying to find what would burn the
absolute cleanest in my body and then
from there we kind of have to figure out
what the macronutrient blend is like how
much fats how much carbs how much
protein of course that was super
important and needed to be basically
pretty high fat and ultimately solved
for that mostly using coconut oil and
then also nuts and seeds and and veggie
protein and things like that but the
real I think difference maker in
addition to figuring out that
macronutrient blends was these
phytonutrients so they were able to find
in my body like what am i deficient in
what do I need more of and what's gonna
break down over time so the bar was a
combination of the right macronutrient
blend using you know fats you know
proteins etc but then also they were
able to grind up their whole food you
know her whole organic supplements into
this bar so I wasn't having to take a
million different pills or things like
that but it was you know ground up you
know it's like no magnesium and you know
you know they're you know probiotics and
things like that promoting gut health
the gut health was the biggest thing
that I kind of came in and they're like
look like your you know your gut health
is not as dialed as it needs to be and
we think over time if you're not
digesting and absorbing these calories
properly you know you were gonna fall
apart outright
yeah so what so what was the nutritional
profile then so you have coconut oil
what else was in it dates yeah so it was
like dried cranberries chia seeds
pumpkin seeds veggie protein is like a
pea powder that the pea protein powder
that they have and then there's actually
one of their products was also a protein
but it was mixed with it's like a
slow-burning carbohydrate bland
basically I don't know exactly all the
various parts again all organics you
know ingredients in there but it's uh
but that was amazing because instead of
kind of these spikes these kind of sugar
spikes it was this longer burn you know
exactly lower glycemic stuff and that's
perfect cuz I'm you know is own one low
heart rate the entire time and dragging
this heavy sled but it's you know you
know slowly and methodically there's not
these like anaerobic bursts so I wasn't
like burning those like fast stores of
glycogen in that way so right yeah are
they gonna package this thing's you know
it's funny there's of course how you get
fat yeah actually yeah but it's so
specific to you yeah
well exactly it's a funny thing you know
I think it's I think it's really cool
they you know right when I got back you
know
Jota tried them on The Today Show and
then Bryant Gumbel we just at HBO real
sports with him he's in my living room
trying them so like you mean it's gotten
some sort of like yeah I profile I know
you got like a lead here in a lot of
people have been reaching out of course
the standard process static you know
will end can we get these column bars
and there's kind of two responses one is
you know that bar was really
specifically tailored : bar for a reason
and it also you know I was burning about
10,000 calories when I was out there and
you know these bars put in about these
bars plus what I had kind of on either
ends of it in the day I was eating about
7,000 calories that's about as much as I
could carry and I was still losing
weight now if we ate 7,000 calories in a
day to day life we all know that that's
probably not unless you're training
super super hard the perfect makeup but
it has asked begged the question and I
think you know there's something that
that you know we are exploring a little
bit which is a custom food solution the
idea of like you know why are we not
fueling our bodies in these custom ways
and of course there's some barriers to
that but is there way to do something
that isn't quite you know a year-long
study of all this blood work and all
this this but in a more simple way to
understand some sort of genetic makeups
of our bodies and what what cleans you
know the Burness burns the cleanest in
our bodies and fuels that's the future
of nutrition or at least performance
nutrition absolutely you know I mean
this Colin bar would be ideal for you in
an Ironman I would have met absolutely
with some electrolyte element to it as
well some hydration strategy but you
know if you're an elite high-performance
athlete and you have the resources to be
able to get that kind of information
that you can drill down on to figure out
and solve your nutritional dilemma
I think would be a massive competitive
advantage especially when look as a
professional triathlete look at Ironman
look at these guys that are at the
absolute tip of the spear the best most
highly trained and they're still running
into problems with nutrition when they
hit you know mile ten exactly nan and
they're starting they start to throw up
on the cone of course it's like there's
a lot of stress he figured out and
learned to solve this kind of problem
100 percent 100 percent and I think that
you know it was fun to have you know
this incredible company behind me with
all the support that they threw my way
to create you know what we did but when
I'm really excited about and what I kind
of you know said to them a year ago when
I percent
how amazing would it be to come back
from this hopefully it's successful
hopefully there's some media buzz around
it and when I get asked questions like
this conversation we're having right now
like how did you do that be like we
solve this with whole food health and
nutrition and by the way we collected
all the data and science on it so in the
next you know several months we're
planning to you know publish of medical
white paper peer-reviewed and you know
proper science turn on that actually
just show open source like here's how we
did it now does that that doesn't
trickle down to the retail product
tomorrow but that is the beginning of
this sort of iteration or at least you
know adding our sort of research to the
larger bucket of people looking at
custom health and nutrition and
hopefully you know that can build to
scale at some point in a way that really
can reach a lot of other people are
certainly high-performing athletes at
first and I think there are the future
of health and though in some ways is
finding this out and actually dictating
our health and nutrition around that in
a business context it's a case study on
the perfect relationship between athlete
and sponsor - yes oh my god because it's
so it so seamlessly integrates with your
mission and what you're doing and now
here you are talking about it still you
don't like that's the way all those kind
of relationships should function I mean
it's it's been an absolute blessing
having been a professional athlete now
for nearly a decade I've been fortunate
to have you know some great partners and
great sponsors along the way but you
know nothing has been you know this for
me is like it's not like a commercial
for standard process right now you just
asked me how did this happen like this
is what I did I had this incredible
partner and we did this amazing thing
and I'm so excited to talk about it
because I'm just passionate about what
we did from the most authentic level of
the whole food healthy nutrition and
solving this high performance question
not with some weird chemical derivative
or isolate but actually being like yeah
like it's whole food nutrition around my
genetic profile with a bunch of smart
people in a room solving this math
equation like we did it and it was
successful we did something that
literally no one in history has ever
done with the human body and it's just a
really fun you know fun to be able to
reflect on that in the way that's sort
of the most meaningful to me and my
background and you did it plant base
exactly exactly
not only the first person to cross
Antarctica unaided but you did it as the
first plant-based birth that's right
yeah you know we can celebrate that
let's talk about the the preparation for
this in terms of fitness training
because I
what's also interesting is that you know
kind of harkening back to this tradition
of great explorers these people come
from a very different kind of background
and lineage they tend to be people from
the military like Lou came from Special
Forces right I mean God done like seven
tours yes yes turn around exactly that's
a more traditional kind of background
for this kind of thing it's what's
unique about you is you're coming from a
professional athlete background and you
know in the way that you approached
nutrition more scientifically and
differently than what had been done
historically your your athletic
preparation for this was also like
finely tuned and pretty unique and
interesting yeah for sure you know it's
I agree with you you know exploration
and you know whatever you want call them
action sports and you know or you know
mountaineering things like that's
haven't necessarily always been in a
more traditional athlete character
category and it's been fun to see you
know some athletes that I really admire
kind of crossing over into this you know
a guy like a Killian Draenei who's
obviously one of the greatest athletes
in the world but also has all the
technical mountaineering skills to do
incredible things or certainly what Alex
Honnold just did you know or even Steve
house you know publishing books about
like how to actually train for the new
output ISM how to be you know think of
yourself as an athlete to think about
climbing mountains or doing something so
it's fun to see that building but you're
absolutely right which is the
traditional background in these types of
things hasn't been necessary
professional athletes taking the mom or
even a training protocol that is of the
similarity of a professional athlete and
so for me you know approaching it with
that mindset having been a professional
triathlete for a number of years and
really approach things in that way it
was fun to look at this problem but also
it was completely unique to me you know
I you know when I was racing triathlon
you know I'm 6 foot tall my race so it
was probably about 158 pounds something
like that you know maybe blow 160 s at
times and that was clearly not gonna cut
it like that writing build was not going
to cut it for Antarctica it was very
clear to me after sitting down a
standard process like I needed to put
some mass on my body not only to be
stronger to pull this 375 pounds sled
out the gate but literally because we
knew I was gonna be you know withering
away
yeah I needed something in the bank to
lose a hundred percent so we targeted
putting me up to about 185 pounds which
we ultimately did get me there I felt
weird to be that had never been that big
in my life but to get my sort of body
weight up that high and so I was like
who can coach me I've had some
incredible coaches along the way in my
life of course they're my swimming
career trifle and etc but kind of wanted
you know a different take on this and so
kind of via you know I don't know just a
couple people making some introductions
I got introduced to this guy named Mike
McCaskill who's based out of Portland
where I'm from and he's an incredible
guy he himself has four World Records
but in things very different than what
I've done northey's very strength
oriented things he's done 5804 for
pull-ups in 24 hours or something like
that the world record and that he pulled
an f-150 truck like 20 miles across
Death Valley or something like that I
mean and he's like this soft-spoken you
know has a background he was a Navy guy
not a Navy SEAL but he was a navy guy
for a long time air traffic controller
there and he's a young guys in his early
30s and he trains and trains athletes
out of this gym called evolution Fitness
by my house that has this altitude
chamber it's a cool place to Train but
anyways I got connected with him and
immediately we just kind of synched not
only because I was like well this guy
knows how to pull heavy things far
clearly Eddie's just down the street
from me but he also is this
high-performing athlete that really
looks at things from the mental side as
well and ultimately my curiosity with
Antarctica as much as it was physical
and there's some serious physical
demands out there which is are obvious
the mental side was my deep curiosity
you know what happens to the brain
you know 54 days alone this expansive
white landscape nothing to see on the
horizon the Sun never setting you know
can you can you harness the power of
that or is that gonna completely defeat
you that seemed like that was gonna be
the make-or-break so Mike really
designed this training protocol for me
that really encapsulated both those
things yes we got me stronger I did a
lot of you know squats and deadlifts and
bench press and you know getting like
bigger and stronger muscle mass more
weight lifting than I've probably done
since I was a good swimmer really you
know I haven't done that kind of work in
a long time but then a lot of body
weights laughs a lot of plyometrics but
ultimately the kind of crux of this was
this combination of this hardcore
fitness you know weight training
with the mental side so he started doing
these circuits for me we'd get my heart
rate jacked up really high by doing all
this sort of you know you know running
on this treadmill uphill
you know lifting weights all this kind
of stuff and then he'd have me put my
feet in ice buckets sit against the wall
do a wall squat but then he would start
yelling like you know fractions I mean a
math problems where he'd hand me a Lego
set and be like solved this Lego set my
hands would be in this ice buckets in a
plank position and then I have to pull
him out and tie knots with ropes and
there's this idea of in Antarctica
completely alone no one else to rely on
myself I had to be completely locked in
both mentally being able to calm my mind
with my heart rate jacked up with the
storm literally raging around me but if
I tied a knot wrong or if I let go of my
tent in that blew away I'm in the middle
of Antarctica alone no tent exactly yeah
for lack of a better word absolutely so
it uh it was intense but the training
was amazing and it was one of those
moments when I found myself in an
article several times in these brutal
storms you know setting up my tent in a
minus 80 degree wind chill when it's
minus 30 out in 50 60 mile-per-hour
winds just brutal conditions and I'm
going oh if I freak out right now or if
my mind is not calm or I'm not executing
like properly or I'm exhaust at the end
of this you know 15 hour day or whatever
it is like you know this is how you lose
your life or this is how you get into
big trouble and so that training with
Mike both combining that physical and
the mental and these intense
environments was just an incredible way
to train and prepare for this you know
that tip to Mike for sure for what he
did there yeah it's those little things
in something like that like some tiny
little thing that you overlooked or that
you screwed up because you didn't have
your mind set right yet end up like up
ending the entire thing for a hundred
percent and the Antarctica you know the
the crazy thing when I compare you know
polar expeditions to you know Himalayan
mountaineering you know climbing Everest
or other bigger expeditions I've done in
the mountains is you know there's in the
mountains there's probably more
objective hazard meaning of course
there's there's avalanche risk you could
you know fall down a big cliff both
Antarctica and mountains of course have
crevasses
but in varying degrees and so there's
that kind of that heightened intensity
in a mountain but even in you know
Himalayan mountaineering you might climb
up to a couple high camps but then you
might sit there for four or five days
relax in a base camp go down the
mountain and rest and recover and wait
for that kind of epic one epic summit
push whereas in Antarctica
it's 54 days and it's nonstop every
single day so I didn't have enough food
and of course I'm racing Lou and so I
didn't have enough time to basically
take a day off in 54 days I didn't take
a single rest day so that meant if it
was you know like I said 50 60
mile-per-hour winds
I was out of my tent not going oh I
should take a shortened day it's a full
day it's a 12-hour 13 hour day of
pulling my sled I've been on either end
of it it's two hours of melting snow to
create water you know putting my boots
on you know packing everything up which
is not easy when the winds blowing and
everything and then setting the tent up
and doing all this as well as of course
trying to share this story with the
world so I'm posting you know an
Instagram every single night I'm
carrying the satellite modem that is you
know posting besides it's a whole sort
of process of the days in which I mean
maybe that doesn't sound like a lot but
there was no day that wasn't 17 hours
long for 54 days in a row completely by
myself having to do every task shoveling
snow and so every sequence of the day
one little misstep in any of those you
know hundreds of details throughout the
day could you know begin a sudden
disaster for sure yeah no question about
it
alright so just to be clear you have
this sled that you're gonna be pulling
and it ends up weighing 375 right yeah
yeah 375 pounds not an ounce more or
less after you know basically you know
analyzing this thing six ways to Tuesday
to try to figure out like what are the
essential things that I need and not one
thing more yep exactly and so how much
of that is so it's it's your food
obviously how much did the food way so
the food weight I think it came in
around 2 to 20 something like right to
20 so that's a you know significant
portion of it and that's obviously gonna
decline over time then you have you have
your tents yeah you have your stove yeah
if your sleeping bag yeah you have extra
gear I would imagine a little bit you
didn't bring a lot of backup gear in
case stuff broke yeah so kind of once
you started weighing all the components
of the sled and realizing you know 375
was a stretch for me to even be able to
pull at all and definitely couldn't have
been any heavier than that and it was
pretty much on my limit right at the
gate and so I realized I couldn't bring
any kind of extra anything so the other
big weight component that you didn't
mention there which was fuel so the way
that you get water of course by melting
snown so that of course is white gas I
took about 15 liters of that and so that
way do you know another 20 or so pounds
there but you know food and fuel were
the main things but there was not enough
is like extra ski nope can't bring that
like extra tent no can't bring that I
mean I literally didn't bring an extra
pair of underwear I didn't change my
clothes the entire time for 54 days so
that I could get an extra like hundred
calories of food in my sled and you know
I was right down to it at the end there
I was down to my last bag or so of food
so it was I mean the calculation is very
tight I'm being able to do this crossing
without being resupplied so every you
know out little ounce mattered but I
mean honestly that first day I get I get
dropped off you know Lou and I get
dropped off actually a mile apart from
each other we're equidistant from the
first Waypoint the first kind of GPS
marker on the map and you know we'd been
we'd built this sort of a bit of a
camaraderie but there's clearly a little
bit of tension and you know we're both
wanting to be first at this thing but
we're still on the same plane and we're
realizing we're both attempting this
thing so it's not like we wish ill on
each other you know we give ourselves
each other a hug and say hey you know I
hope you make a safe and successful
crossing but I think in the back of both
our minds is like but I hope I'm first
yeah but I I'm looking at his gear and
I'm like man this guy knows his stuff
not only is he have this military
background but he's actually done more
miles in Antarctica man hauling a sled
than any person in history so he's done
at this point about you know 2,000 plus
miles now after this expedition 3 that
more than 3,000 miles in Antarctica and
I've done 69 miles in Antarctica on this
much smaller expedition on the last
degree of latitude collars grand-slam
that's like young you know upstair kid
come in and of course I've done climbed
a lot more mountains and done stuff in
him and so it's not like I don't have a
background I used the dude when it comes
to an ark yes and he brought an extra
pair of skis and he did bring an extra
pair of skis but what his way out at his
so his sled ended up being about 40
pounds lighter than mine to start
because he took he was eating less
calories per day he was eating 5500
calories per day which ultimately in the
end he lost about 40 or 50 pounds and I
lost only 20 pounds I think that was a
big difference in the end he had more
food left over at the end he did it so
it's very interesting the way that like
we kind of we definitely had different
strategies a hundred percent and I'm not
in I would say on the very first day I
get dropped off I've got my
I'm packing it up before I take even a
single step I'm actually securing stuff
in my sled and I actually used a
secondhand sled believe it or not I
solved for all these things but I found
a sled of another guy who I knew in the
UK and he let me you know use this sled
which he had taken to the South Pole
before so I'm figuring out like this
actually is a you know battle-tested
sled so it's good in that sense but I
reached down I pull the strap tight on
the sled the first time I haven't taken
a single step and ping the the strap
bridge miles ago
and so I've you know I strap I strap
everything down I get going I go for
about an hour or two and I am just
suffering I'm actually there's a video
clip of me but I'm crying I'm actually
crying underneath my god was night now
have frost on my nose because the tears
are literally freezing to my face and I
pick up my satellite phone I call him to
Jenna I'm like so Jenna I think we may
have named our project the right thing
it appears that this is impossible and I
see Lou like disappear on the horizon
just like strong and steady like in this
sort of like like I said military March
and he clearly I was like well he maybe
had a better strategy than I did here
and so that was a tough moment for sure
right out the gate so just to back it up
a little bit because I want to track
through this yeah in a logical manner so
Lou had been public about doing this
much earlier than you yes so I would
imagine when suddenly at the last minute
was like October when you announce that
you're doing this and you guys
ultimately end up pushing off like when
like early November 3rd yes he's like
there's weeks beforehand he must have
been like is this guy yes he doing
right so what happened the first time
and I think people are confused like why
you guys on the same plane like why is
this happening in sage because you have
this window right yeah only ways it's
gonna happen so the first moment that
you meet him it must have been awkward
he must have been like what is guy doing
yes yes this is my thing so certainly
you know I think that he was he wasn't
thrilled and he certainly wasn't happy
that I announced so late I certainly you
know that was a strategic advantage to
kind of wait until the last minute
although I didn't kind of make up that
strategy your here's the thing that you
you're like a smiling friendly very
affable guy but underneath the
surface you're a competitive beast man
like I don't trust you yeah like you got
there's there's like there's something
like really competitive underneath this
like friendly veneer you know I
absolutely it would have to be in order
for you to go and do these things yeah
no absolutely you know I was you know
passionate about trying to be the first
in this case and that was it's
interesting because two things happen
one I felt very competitive with Lou and
for me it was like absolutely like not
only am i racing history here but I'm
racing Lou head-to-head but at the same
time I also have this like great respect
for anyone who's putting themselves out
in this environment and so it was this
weird kind of interplay in my mind being
this competitive athlete that clearly is
a big part of me but also somebody who
generally like resonates love and
compassion and empathy and so I actually
found myself every single day was kind
of a gratitude practice that I just
generally have of sending love and
positivity towards Lou as well as being
like I'm waking up early this morning so
I can go more miles than you and so it's
this interesting interplay but yeah
absolutely
so you meet him it was weird at first
how do you get over that so we met in
puntarenas which is southern chile where
you take the cargo plane that ultimately
takes you to antarctica and at this
point adam Skolnick the new york times
he had come down to cover this story he
wasn't gonna be able to come to an
article cause it's ridiculously
prohibitively expensive to go to
Antarctica that way but he the new at
the time sent him down to an hour to
puntarenas and so the they set up like a
dinner or meet-and-greet for Lou and I a
day before we're both flying down to
Antarctica and you had Anatomy I never
met him yet I had sent him one email
just to say actually the day before I
announced just say hey by the way
tomorrow I'm announcing his project I'm
also doing this you know wishing you all
the best luck we should probably talk
because we're gonna be you know doing
this at the same time maybe cordon make
some coordination but you know nothing
else just want to introduce myself and
say hello and I got back a somewhat
worse What did he say yeah you know for
me you know good luck buddy it just it
was just kind of like he could read
between the lines of like oh this young
American who doesn't understand the
history and respect you know it says is
it interesting that conversation gonna
call yeah yeah you have to put your time
before you step up to something yeah and
but you know I could but I will say
although that you know that first email
wasn't the most pleasant to receive from
him and the first time we met you know
there was there was although kind of
below it you know some maybe you know
some competitive nature it was generally
pretty affable I mean we met and it was
a little bit awkward and all this the
reporters are looking at us they want to
take a picture of us like shaking hands
before this duel across Antarctica but
also you know like I said you know his
his friend died three years ago trying
this thing you know he's doing this for
an incredibly honorable cause he's
raising money for these military
charities things like that and you know
I think once he got to know me a little
bit better he realized like oh like this
you know this is a guy like you just
said like yes he's a competitor yes he's
trying to do this but at the same time
like it wasn't like I was like don't
look at me it wasn't like some like like
I picture like a Eminem MMA like Conor
McGregor like you know press conference
or his trash-talking so like it couldn't
be like me you know we had a drink we
chatted he told me about his story I
told all of my background you know we
weren't like giving up our like exact
strategies or anything like that but
like it was friendly although I'll be it
a little bit awkward but yes there's
only one logistics operator so we
literally ended up on the same the same
place we actually he originally was
going to take a different route than I
was going to take and so we didn't know
we're gonna be dropped off at the exact
same point but the day before we get
dropped off he actually came to me and
said hey I'm actually being dropped off
at the same point as you based on some
of the other logistics and weather in
the area and things like that and so in
that moment it was like alright this is
not just this is not just a race from
different rights of this business like
actually dropped off same point same
moment same day ready go
so they drop you off but ultimately you
start like a mile apart from each other
on a parallel track right so it's not
like you're standing right now oh my god
like go I guess it could have been
actually that they were like they sort
of suggested that and we were kinda like
that would be like pretty weird and
you're like these sleds are so heavy
that like you're going in a inching
forward so fortunately they you know
parallel plan like you said equidistant
from the first Waypoint but one mile
apart from one another to begin but I
mean a mile in Antartica you can see on
a clear day it was
beautifully clear day when we got
dropped off you can see forever I mean
you literally mean some mild you're like
oh he's just like right there and like I
said I'm struggling I'm crying in my my
ski goggles you tell that story you told
that story at that little gathering I
went to in New York like taking that
first pole and just being like this
thing's not moving at all like what have
I got myself into I mean it was it was
brutal and like I said picking up that
phone call not one of the proudest phone
calls I've ever made but to tell Jen
after we spent a year of our life
planning and doing every little detail
with standard process with the food and
trying to get everything perfectly right
to like come out at first and go like oh
maybe we didn't get it right but you
must have liked taking the sled out and
on ice to it but the thing is it's it's
really hard to tell and this this was
something that I kind of know more now
of course I didn't have as much of
experience as looted but really what
dictates the friction more than anything
of course is the snow conditions and of
course and you know academically or
logically in my mind I understand that
but it's very different to be like oh if
it's loose and unconsolidated snow a 375
pounds sled feels like a 600 pound sled
but if it's less icy you know sheer you
know veneer surface it's gonna feel like
a hundred pound sled I mean so the same
sled on different snow conditions and
this had been an El Nino year and it
just turned out that actually it was one
of the most difficult expedition years
that an America has seen in a long time
in fact Lou and I were the first
expeditions to be dropped off that
season no one else wasn't empting this
full traverse but people were attempting
various you know coast to pole crossings
or there's some smaller you know group
trips down there and several expeditions
big expeditions from some guys who were
really talented a British guy who has a
world record one of the other bigger
polar explorers in the US all had to
abandon their projects about halfway
through because they got stuck in such
deep snow they couldn't move their sled
and so Lou and I can encounter that
straight out of the gate and that was me
going like Oh like it's not just how
heavy my sled is that I proved I could
pull it in a gym or in a test situation
but being out here and also that first
day it was overwhelming like I'm not
gonna lie like I get dropped off I'm in
the middle of Antarctica by myself it's
minus 25 degrees I know I'm not gonna
speak to anybody for months like I'm
afraid that like some bad weather is
gonna come in before I kind of hit my
stride I'm just overwhelmed by the
entire emotion and the vastness of this
entire situation it was just
one of those you know tough moments of
you know fear doubt all of the things
kind of creeping up in your mind and
having to persevere and push through
them so that first day you wanted to get
to that way Jenna's like just get to
this way yes how what was the distance
so actually it was actually the first
waypoints actually this start so you get
dropped off on the ice shelf so you're
at basically you know frozen see what
for a frozen ocean essentially that
you're standing on you can't really
visually tell the difference between
where the continent starts and the ice
shelf because it's very you know deep
ice at that point there but the plane
dropped us off so that we could be
equidistant to the first Waypoint
further out on the ice shelf about three
miles like adding three miles to a
thousand mile journey didn't seem like
that big of a thing so we could be
separated at the start but that first
Waypoint is really like the starting
point and I'm already failing before
that so I'm like Jenna's like how far
are you from the first Waypoint when I
call and I'm like I'm like point six
three miles I guys might as well so I
was a million miles but I'm saying it's
like you know a half a mile basically
she's like okay look like get to that
first Waypoint set your tent up you'll
feel like you made some project progress
and we can kind of you know recalibrate
from there and so I finally make it to
that first Waypoint it was brutal I get
in the tent I'm exhausted I've only been
outside for three hours because we got
dropped off later in the day and so it
wasn't like a full day of polling and so
I get in that tent I call Jenna again
that night so we plan to have a safety
call every single evening just as sure
she could kind of check in on my mental
acuity and just kind of check in on how
I'm doing you know it's not like
inexpensive the lakes not go satting on
the phone like you know important to
make this phone call to her and she's
like look tomorrow it's gonna be really
hard obviously but I had been really
curious about these flow States and kind
of these meditative places that I wanted
to find in my mind and so I've been
telling her that all in my training and
she was like she said to me she's like
try to find the flow tomorrow even if
for 30 seconds even if for a minute like
just try to find like that inner peace
it's gonna be hard out there and so I
remember the next morning I woke up and
it was kind of a pivotal moment for me
which is kind of embarking on my first
full day and I'm a big believer that you
know we are the stories we tell
ourselves there's been various mantras
with me throughout different times but
this mantra just kind of came to me in
that moment I woke up on that first full
day and I said out loud to myself I said
Colin you are strong you are capable you
are strong you are capable and that kind
of
became like my mantra every morning firm
from then on out and I getting out in
the conditions that day Lewis long gone
on the horizon I just focus Louie way
ahead yeah I was focused just on my own
like just making progress some way and
you know that next day was brutal I
think I made it you know eight and a
half miles one of my you know slowest
slowest and most challenging days but I
remember late in that day kind of eight
and a half nine hours into that day I
tapped into this flow state for a minute
like I just found this like minute of
calm in this ten hour day of just brutal
like suffering and it was just that
first glimmer of hope of like Oh like if
I can figure out how to get my systems
right if I can just kind of calm my mind
a little bit I mean I imagine as a
swimmer as triathlete along things
you've done you've tapped into that
place from time to time where you're
like oh like there is a way to kind of
calm this down but my body can actually
function a pretty high level but when
your mind is racing it's so heavy I
can't do this at all these things you
wind yourself yeah it takes time you
know the body it's like there there has
to be this merging of body and mind
where it finally sinks up and it's like
okay now I understand what you're doing
here yeah and I can like accommodate
this but at first it's a manic chaotic
thing until you kind of settle into okay
this is there's a rhythm here absolutely
and you know for me it's funny because I
feel like I'm confronting the opposite
of this coming from all this solitude
and being back out in the world and
doing interviews and things like this
now it's the opposite like I was
unwinding from being in that digital
world planning my project all the
last-minute logistics you know flying on
planes all this kind of stuff to all
this sudden like I'm alone it's quiet
it's still and I hadn't found that
stillness within yet because I was still
like you said in this sort of manic
phase but getting that glimmer of hope
on that first day was really important
to me to give me that confidence that if
I continued with this process day after
day that hopefully I would find that on
a more regular basis so you have this
strategy of breaking this up into like
an interval workout right like eight
times 90 minutes yeah so my original
strategy and I had kind of played with
this the the other expedition I done in
training as I did a crossing of
Greenland not alone with a group of
other people but I tried to kind of
operate autonomously as much as I can to
sort of simulate the
this was just a two months before in
arctica I went and did that 400 miles
and there I kind of found this rhythm of
going for 90 minutes and being able to
take a quick break you know the most
important thing over a long duration I
was gonna pull my sled for about 12
hours plus per day is you know I'd have
breakfast inside the tent in the morning
and then dinner at night but in between
all I'm seeing these column bars and I
realize it's not like you're gonna have
like one big lunch and like pour 4000
calories in your stomach it's more like
an endurance event where you're gonna
you know this kind of steady dough of
100 200 calories that are pretty you
know steady rhythm and so I found that
every 90 minutes I could you know take a
break pretty short break where I could
drink some water and eat some column
bars and refuel and kind of keep my sort
of glycogen stores you know on an even
keel throughout the day but it's crazy
in Antarctica you know you actually get
pretty warm pulling a sled there's this
there's this phrase which is you know
you sweat you die you really like don't
I want to talk about it you know you
can't sweat when you're out there
because you know the second you sweat
it's fine for the moment you're sweating
but the second you stop I mean your body
temperature and the clothes on your body
will literally freeze to you you go
hypothermic within a matter of minutes
and so it's this kind of this
comfortably cool of like pushing hard
enough to keep your body warm and get
warmed up but not hard enough that
you're sweating it's is this weird thing
but the second you stop so as a result
of that sometimes I'd have relatively
thin layers on but to stop and take a
drink of water I would need to put my
huge puffy jacket on within a matter of
you know 10 15 seconds so in the front
of my sled I'd have my thermos which is
how the water didn't freeze and then a
big puffy jacket and so I would stop
after 90 minutes put this huge puffy
jacket on even if I was only gonna stop
for two or three minutes put the jacket
on and then drink this warm water my
thermos eat some Collin bars and put it
all back in the sled and take off again
before I got too cold right so when
you're moving you're basically stripping
down to like base layers right and what
is the ambient temperature yeah so the
average ambient temperature throughout
the journey was about minus 25 degrees
which seemed crazy to be in it's crazy I
mean it's a how could you be moving and
like not be absolutely freezing no
matter how much clothes you were wearing
yeah I've had to like describe that cold
in different ways of like you know it's
like oh we understand that's really cold
but I realize like the best way I can
describe it way of
standing there is there's uh there's a
photo that actually used in my TED talk
a couple years ago to try to describe
this cold and I took a cup of boiling
water on that expedition in the South
Pole in 2016 and I threw it in the air
and it immediately turns to ice like in
this puff of smoke so boiling water to
ice in an instant that kind of gives you
a sense of how cold this is and that's
with no wind and of course the wind
chill can you know ratchet down like I
said - 50 - fixes 60 - 70 degrees very
commonly but it's a bizarre thing our
bodies are capable of keeping themselves
pretty darn warm when we're moving but
the second were stopped that just
completely changes because that heart
rate you know you know drops and so yeah
there were days particularly when there
wasn't wind when there was when I pretty
much always had to have at least like my
gore-tex like jacket windproof like
layer on but a lot of the time you know
there were there were days when it was
still in common - 20 - 25 degrees out
where I would literally be down to a
base layer like just a base layer you
know hat goggles gloves like all of that
always pretty much but you know you
could get warm but it would also be like
you'd be like okay and you just it was
more like I was changing at all times I
got to be like okay I need to be down
for this jacket for 20 minutes okay now
I'm a little bit to go put the jacket
back on and switching and this and
that's when it's really easy to go like
oh it's such a pain in the ass so like
change like my gloves again or like put
this jacket on that's when you can just
really kind of like let your guard down
but that's when you go like oh but now
I'm sweating or oh but now I'm too cold
and my body's shutting down and whatnot
and so it was kind of I think of it as
like an airplane pilot you know with
this constant checklist of like this
safety check like how your feet how are
your hands your nose okay how are your
feet our hands or your nose okay how's
your body temperature how's your food
supply how's your this and kind of just
constantly running this checklist in my
mind which became second nature
eventually but seemed like a lot to keep
up with that first of kind of almost
like you know of a pasta meditation or
an awareness practice we're just
constantly being aware of each inch of
your body and how it needs to either
change or how you need to you know make
an adjustment to stay in this kind of
you know homeostasis or kind of qualm
gonna quiet you know temperature there
must have been days where the conditions
were really good and the snow conditions
were smooth where you felt like you
could just haul some ass yeah you have
to hold that oh yeah cuz you can't sweat
yeah exactly I mean there's you know
there's the epic storms and the battles
I had out there
are maybe more exciting to talk about
but yeah there were days where it was
calm it's blue skies you could see
forever you know the ground conditions
were good but in those days yeah it's
like you just said like okay now you're
tempted to be like okay I want to push
like super hard but like you can't you
know like you can just like run around
out there I mean the sleds still super
heavy and so yeah it was like it was a
lot of patience required day by day and
it really required just being in this
methodical
you know incremental gains in those
90-minute sections one of the reasons
that I started breaking my days up into
that because even a whole day just
seemed too long at first like it was
just like break it up so I was like okay
I wake up I say my mantra you're strong
you're a capable then the next thing I
do is I light my stove say it out loud
yeah out loud to myself and why not yeah
exactly
shout it out the next thing light my
match light my stove okay that's the
next part of the day okay on that point
while the water's boiling I'm putting my
socks back on so I'm putting I basically
stuff would get wet throughout the day
with ice and snow the condensation of my
breath on my mask and things the only
way to dry that inside the tent really
is to put it inside of your sleeping bag
or against your body and so all this
stuff would be inside my sleeping bag
there was actually a couple times when I
was having trouble with the skins on the
bottom of my skis and I literally had to
put my skis inside a sleeping bag as
well so were you barefoot in the
sleeping bag when I actually was I
actually found that I slept the best
barefoot and allowed my I would put my
socks down my base layer pants so that
they would dry against my skin and
actually there's an interesting thing
that you do with your feet or that I do
with my feet anyways I know some other
guys that do this in really cold places
but I would have a thin base layer sock
on like a really really thin sock and
then I would put a plastic bag next over
my feet I'm so literally from my from my
oatmeal in the morning there'd be a bag
that I would you know use every single
day and yeah we put that over my feet
and then over top of that I would put a
thick wool sock and then of course my
boot which is really warm and the reason
I would do that is that would create a
vapor barrier inside of my sock so if my
feet did get a little sweaty which I of
course I didn't want them to at all but
if they did it would just be that one
sock on the inside because on a long
expedition if you start sweating inside
of your boots of course your socks get
wet your feet get cold but what actually
happens is the boots know the boot
themselves start to collect snow and
condensation in them so
keeping the console's right and they're
never gonna dry there's no way to really
you know get them as dry as you but
putting a plastic bag on your foot is
gonna cause your foot to sweat right
because there's no right reason so that
is a that's like the one exception to
the rule you're not gonna wrap your body
in you know you know plastic but in this
case to keep the boots dry it was almost
better to have this kind of you know hot
plastic bag around your feet essentially
at the end of day so my feet were moist
at the end of the day not like dripping
in sweat or anything but they would
build up a little bit of condensation
there but yeah that all came out of my
sleeping bag and it was just easy
incremental parts of the day it was like
okay then I take them on a sleeping bag
then I pour the water in my thermos then
I do I mean it was like that sequence of
the days and it was almost like just
looking at these little incremental
steps throughout the day then the
totality of the day or certainly the
week or the months that I was out there
was way too vast it was just having to
break it down in these compartmentalize
things and see if I could repeat the
same day over and over and over again
and this strange sort of meditative
monotony without like losing your mind
yes so you have this great story about
overtaking Lou so you're about seven
days and yeah where you start you
realize you're gaining on him right and
there's a little bit of like tit-for-tat
where you guys are passing each other a
little bit and your tents are yeah it's
like this sort of dueling thing you can
see him in the distance yes so walk me
through that experience because I think
psychologically it's super interesting
yeah I mean it's an intense moment for
sure because after that like I said that
first day I see him disappear and I
think you know I just gotta execute my
plan and you know this will be what it
will be the competitive juices are still
flowing but I'm also like I got to
survive out here I got to prove that I
can move this sled I got it you know so
I almost forget about him for the first
little bit but then sure enough on the
sixth day at the end of the fifth day I
see you know his tent far on the horizon
so I push a little extra far that day to
get kind of within striking distance of
his tent I set up my tent only probably
bout 15 minutes away from his tent and
the closest we ever camp to one another
and I wake up early the following
morning thinking you know what maybe I
can kind of get a little bit of a jump
on the day and I wake up and it's a
whiteout day complete whiteout and when
it's whiteout you know as expansive as
Antarctica can be when the sun's out I
mean the sun's always up 24 hours a day
but when there's no clouds it's the
opposite it's like this myopic like
insular experience it's just white on
white you can barely see one step in
front of you and I've got my compass
strapped to my chest and I'm looking
down at my compass
you know navigating in this whiteout and
you know I see Lu Lu's tent and I try to
kind of go go around him a little bit
just give him a little bit of distance
but it's like you can't really go extra
distance we're trying to go in the same
direction and as I'm passing his tent I
see that I hear the sonic kind of this
cough and this unzipping of the tent you
know Lu kind of pops his head out of
this tent and gives me this curved
surreal wave and it's just this bizarre
moment of he's like two competitors but
also out in the middle of nowhere this
whiteout in Antarctica
good morning or at the end of day it was
early it was early in the driver get you
got a jump on him yeah part of your days
a little bit earlier than he a little
bit earlier than he did and yeah so I
end up I end up passing him and I'm
continuing on you know Khan trying to
stay focus on my progress and it's
really challenging to navigate in the
whiteout and this is one of the first
major white other ended up being tons
throughout the entire project but it's
day six and this was the first like
really bad whiteout that I'd have so I'm
kind of just kind of getting my bearings
quite literally with my compass trying
to find my way and it's tough and I look
back and you know Lu's taking his tent
down and here he comes and I was like oh
like it's a whiteout I'm in front of him
on the same path that he's trying to do
you know whether he's doing it and
purposely or not doesn't matter it's
like he can see the bearing in me so
it's probably easier to navigate and I'm
thinking why did I just get like taken
by another veteran Yahoo like he's like
yeah but you know yeah that's a total
Jen say yeah and I'm not I'm certainly
not saying that he was like you know
going in my tracks to like go fast or
nothing like that it was just like it's
whiteout you can see nothing but you can
see me he's fine it's like it's just
easier like it's just day yeah did the
mental duress yes and so sure enough you
know what it didn't go on like that for
very long and he pulls up he pulls up
beside me and you know we he kind of he
kind of just strikes it was it's really
it's just this bizarre moment and he
pulls up beside me and kind of strikes
up a pro casual commerce he's like hey
good more to me like you know everything
all right with your harness because the
way I pull my harness
actually it looks like it's kind of
messed up visually but it's just the
specific way that I pull it and I know
that it's fine but I can see why he's
like looking at me like I'm like just
kinda like critique my like pulling
technique right dealers he likes I to
get in your head trying to get in my
head is he this and that and so I just
say to him I cut him short and I just
say I say hey Lu look we both know the
stakes out here we both know there's a
ton of pressure on us you know this is a
really intense moment we're both meant
to be out here solo unsupported like let
this be the last time that we speak to
one another and it wasn't I wouldn't say
it in like a rough or mean way it was
like yo like I'm sending you love but
like we're both out here on these solo
expeditions of course we might tip for
that cross each other's paths in some
weird way like this but you know let
this be you know we're not gonna be out
here like chit-chatting because it could
be a reason that people would would say
that that constitutes support absolutely
I mean if certainly if the continuation
of the expedition I mean like I said we
were you know beside each other for 15
seconds or something we had like the
most briefest of all conversations but
yeah of course if we were beside each
other for the next week or two weeks
it'll be like well that's not a solo
expedition that's you guys like out here
together in whatever so you know we
crossed each other's past in this moment
and like I said we had had given each
other a hug you know at the starting
line and kind of you know at this moment
just kind of like look each other's eyes
a memory I'm kind of putting his goggles
up and I can see his eyes and he's like
all right like it was just kind of this
like coy smile I couldn't read into it I
was like you see messing with me is not
is he just like being you know nor was
he you know I'd but you're saying that
or yeah I didn't really know but it was
super brief and it was just like kind of
like okay like both of us just like kind
of like each other again not in this
like rough or combative way certainly in
a competitive way but in a way that was
like okay because we both know how hard
the journey is in front of both of us
and we like we of there 7 billion people
on the planet like there's one other
person like going through this other
thing so you can't help but have some
like love and passion wants that we're
day6 you know we think it's gonna take
50 60 70 days and so it's like hey man
like best of luck to you and so we split
up but it's of course funny when you try
to split up in an article like you said
it's like two tortoises racing yeah okay
see you later it's like that thing where
you're like say goodbye to someone and
then you both turn to say where exactly
on the same elevator yeah a little
chitchat so anyways so anyways yeah we
spoke like I said a few sentences to one
another we split up and I decide in my
mind that day I was like wow like clear
I think Lou probably got his gear a
little more dialed than me he's
definitely got a lighter sled he's got
more experience than me but I was like
I'm gonna stay out here longer than him
so I kind of got it in my mind that day
and I was like okay if Lou goes for 10
hours today I'm going for 11 hours of
Lou goes for 11 hours I'm going for 12
hours you know I'm really gonna try to
just go further than him that day and so
he eventually we you know we weren't
right beside each other we were probably
/ you know as much as a quarter mile or
half a mile you know one maybe a little
bit in front of the other then someone
would take break and you know eat lunch
or whatever that was and was kind of you
know back and forth and then eventually
you know I did see him set up his tent
and I decided - you're gonna push him
you know push on and you know set up my
tent and I pushed on another hour and
ended up about two miles in front of him
I didn't really know this at the time
but you know Jenna would relay me from
time to time you know blogs or things
written and you know the next morning
his blog you know it says the race is on
so he'd been calling home and you know
reporting his status you know totally
normal New York Times have been
reporting on it and all this kind of
stuff and his blog was like the race is
on acknowledging that I had passed him
and I was in front of him but also being
like it's a long way to go like we got a
long time out here I'm not too worried
about this kind of two mile gap that's
opened up with you know nine hundred
some miles still to go or whatever it
was but on that point for words I
decided to wake up early the following
morning as well the tiger yeah the race
is on
okay but it's it the thing is is that
what mostly got to me in that moment the
intensity of that moment was it was
gonna be really challenging to be with
an eye sight of each other I mean first
of all the intention was to do this
thing solo so both of us wanted that
anyways for just like the the nobility
of this challenge was to be completely
alone and so we both recognized that and
I think you know realized that for one
another but also it was just I mean if
it was gonna be mean day six we start
doing be too
in 89 we started doing that for the next
like three four or five weeks like back
and forth like you're a mile head no no
no I'm I'll head oh no no this thing has
like it was gonna like I think it was
gonna wear us both down in a pretty
insane way so I tried to get up early
the next morning stayed ahead and
ultimately you know kept kept my
distance out front for the remainder of
the time and that was it so undeniably
though the fact that you two were doing
it you know in tandem in this way pushed
both of you absolutely you know not not
to say that you wouldn't have finished
otherwise but I doubt that it would have
been 54 days no absolutely it would have
been a whole different ballgame no I
mean no I think that you know both of us
have planned to take longer I think both
of us you know and we've had come and
I've had conversation with this
afterwards both of us had you know
thought that on the worst stormy days
like there's really brutal days where
you'd be like okay I'm gonna stay in my
tent granted you're gonna run out of
food if you do that a bunch of times but
maybe I'm gonna eat I'm gonna take the
gamble to eat less but wait out this
storm or something like this but you had
like a five or six day buffer on food
right I did I did you know ultimately I
had about 60 days worth of food but it
you know it you start doing the math
you're going okay I can't really wait
out that many more of these days but I
think you know him and I have both said
to one another like had it been this way
how doing that we would have both if I
would have done 60 or 65 days instead I
finished in 54 and it was just really
you know that pushed us you know I don't
I'm certainly no Roger Bannister but to
make the comparison between you know
breaking the four-minute mile like you
know people say this thing is impossible
Roger Bannister you know breaks the
four-minute mile and I think it's
incredible testament that within the
next 12 months you know several other
people break that mark and so I think it
is similar which is this thing had been
said it's impossible it's impossible
it's impossible and there was something
about two people out there pushing each
other to a higher degree to ultimately
finish this thing and yeah I finished in
54 days and I'm getting ahead of myself
we can backtrack but you know I got to
the finish line and had that one pair of
underwear on desperately wanted to get
out of there wanted to eat some proper
food all these things but I elected to
not have the plane picked me up right
away because I realized lose a couple
days behind me he's about to finish this
extraordinary crossing like I want to be
the first one there to congratulate him
on a historic crossing as
and that's where this you know like I
said that competitor inside of me and
both of us trying to push ourselves to
be the first Lou doing it 56 days is
extraordinary I mean it's an amazing
thing it's something that we both
thought would take much longer and for
us both to do it and him to come in just
you know to two and a half days behind
me was amazing and certainly something
he should be extraordinarily proud of
yeah it was super cool and gentlemanly
for you to stay behind and wait for him
to arrive but it also would have been a
dick move if you weren't there yeah like
it it kind of just it wasn't even you
know of course in the back of mine it's
like oh god I'll be great to be out of
here whatever but like to celebrate the
entire and the entirety of this thing in
our lives like I said you know 7 billion
people on the planet and you know we
both done this one kind of rich random
niche thing but we've both done this
thing and you know I didn't want to be
out in the world being like yeah I got
in my because it's not how I feel I mean
what he did was extraordinary he honored
his friend Henry Worsley in such an
extraordinary way you know to bring that
back to the UK the first British person
do this after this long lineage of
British explorers failing at doing this
for him to be the successful one and to
be the person that's done like I said
more miles than anyone in Antarctica I
mean he's a true legend he's a national
hero there as as you know as the
veterans of all these wars I mean really
you know extraordinary person and I
think it should be very proud and it was
great to just be able to you know
honestly kind of learn from him and be
out there with him and have this shared
experience and it was a really nice
moment
honestly when he did get to the finish
that day and you know he'd set up his
tent and we hadn't had like a 20 or 30
minute chat neither of us had a
face-to-face chat with another human
being you know you know however long and
to be able to just kind of you know
before the the media and all these
things kind of got a hold of this
project for us to just sit there and be
like wow like like soak it in amazing
like that was crazy and talked about the
hardships and you know he had some
really you know challenging moments out
there as well he got caught out in a
whiteout and almost got separated from
his sled I mean he had some really rough
moments out there that he persevered
through so yeah he had one moment where
he decided to like leave some of his
gear behind pull forward and then go
back and get it yeah and it was buried
in the snow exactly I guess that's
something that he's done in the past
when there's been some really tough
conditions and we hit this really deep
snow and him you know this is one of
those weird moments where I actually
think my
naivete helped me out kind of like this
is n beginner's mind like I the snow got
deep and my sled got super heavy as a
result but I was like I guess Antarctica
is really hard you know like I didn't
really know the difference where it's he
had actually covered this section of the
route on a previous expedition that he
did with six guys and so he is has a
journal that he's comparing it off of
and going like wait I was on this
section before with this having of a
sled moving this many miles like what's
going on and so I think he made the
decision like oh this must just be like
a couple of mile weird section with this
like weird snowdrift I'm gonna ferry my
sled because it's too heavy take half
the weight out bury my sled ahead and go
back and he did that a couple of times
successfully and then all of a sudden
the weather can change in Antarctica
Creek really quickly and he turns around
to go back and his tracks have been
blown over and he's separated from where
his tent is where his food supplies and
all this kind of stuff and I mean gosh
even imagining that for me like sends
shivers down my spine I can only imagine
how scary that could have been yeah and
so he you know fortunately was able to
find his sled and then you know he have
quickly put up his tent and kind of took
a breather for the second half that day
understandably so because that happened
to me actually one time when I got a
little bit turned around and confused
and I was tripping over some sister oogi
I actually was like okay this is true he
is he's big huge kind of like we were
getting yeah so you know sister Oogie
basically a lot of people picture
Antarctica being this flat blank white
landscape right and you know first of
all the South Poles at 9,000 310 feet I
start at sea level so I'm pulling the
sled uphill all the way to the South
Pole which I arrived to on the fortieth
day but also these snow drifts you know
Antarctica is the largest desert in the
world so it actually doesn't get that
much precipitation and so you've got
these big kind of wind drifts kind of
almost like frozen waves of ocean you
know just sitting there and so you're
pulling your sled over thousands of
speed bumps essentially per day this is
true so spooky and when it's whiteout
ANSYS true ghee it's really hard to make
progress because you can't see where
your feet are I was tripping and falling
you know a number of times and there was
one time you know it's kind of second
half of the project when I was pretty
beaten down I've been in a long in a
multi-day storm and I was tripping
through this is true you know I'm going
like wow like maybe if I go a little bit
east or a little bit west or where I am
I can find a path because sometimes
would be like really
to screw you in an area but then it
would be a little bit less based on like
where the winds were and so I actually
did unclip from my sled just for a
second to kind of like go explore like
maybe a quarter mile one direction the
other and I take about two hundred steps
to the right of my sled I remember this
and I look back and I can't even see my
sled anymore and it's the same thing
nothing as intensive what Lou went
through cuz I had only gone about 200
steps I was like oh wait no okay that's
my lifeline yep I need to let go and tie
back in immediately to that so I pretty
much magic yeah couldn't find it it's
just like I mean it's soda soaring in
out there I mean it's white on white on
white on white and so it's just this you
know it's only a momentary thing where I
couldn't I couldn't see it and then like
the wind blew and I could see it again I
was like you know your heart you know
just recovers but you're like okay like
you could be walking around for hours
yes right there and we can find it yeah
and so but that's you know that's ones
differentiating factor between you know
polar exploration mountaineering
mountaineering you are typically
separated from your tent and your supply
is very commonly up on you know
mountains cuz you can't carry everything
with you but in the polar environment
you've kind of always got your tent
right there unless you do something
silly and disconnect from your your sled
which you know and I did in this case
the thing with this sister Oogie is you
just can't get any momentum going yeah
it's just constantly like you know
rocking it forward yeah I mean the
biggest thing with pulling a sled that
heavy is the inertia the initial sort of
force to get it moving forwards right
what it's moving when you can just
cruise yeah you can kind of glide I mean
it's still a very slow methodical energy
is basically taking from a stead stop to
momentum and so once you can carry
livable mentem and get the skis going
it's still like I said very very slow
and in the grand scheme of things but
you can get you can get momentum going
but it's just roogie basically you're
going up over these like two foot speed
bumps so your sled over and over again
it's like you have to pull it up over
the sled and then it crashes down up
over it and crashes down up or they get
scratched down and just like you can't
get any rhythm
you can't get your feet to sort of step
be stable because you've got skis on the
bottom of your feet which you know
sometimes I'd say skis people like oh so
you were like downhill skiing it's like
no no I was wearing skis basically has
glorified snowshoes so that you've your
weight is dispersed across the weight of
the snow and there's skins on the bottom
of them that provide friction to allow
you to basically pull against the
of that so there's no there's no skiing
involved in this it's it's basically
walking not even really like you know
proper Nordic skiing I mean a little bit
but not even really it's mostly just
like this long trudge but the skis give
you a little bit more grip on the snow
and the elevation gain man yeah I mean
and so it's it's literally like you're
its I mean 9,000 feet of gain right yes
isn't the highest point like ten
thousand two hundred yeah there's some
where I tend to oh the heights well the
highest mountain in Antarctica is Mount
Vinson which is 16,000 feet which I
climbed on the Seven Summits project
explores Grand Slam but the the highest
point up on the polar plateau is called
the Titan dome and that's over 10,000
feet we kind of skirted around the edge
of that but actually from the South Pole
still had to go up to about 9,800 feet
was my highest point was roughly ninety
eight hundred feet and what's weird is
that you know we think of altitude in
terms of you know losing our breath at
high altitudes you know near the equator
you know I'm not a scientist I might not
get this perfectly right but basically
the atmospheric pressure is a little bit
different at the North and South Poles
and so 9,000 feet actually feels more
like 12 or 13,000 feet out here so it's
basically like pulling a 307 pounds sled
uphill you know up in the the High
Sierras are the the Rockies or something
like that yeah I mean at the end of days
when I'd be shoveling snow I'd have to
shovel snow to like put it on the edge
of my tent for wind blocks and things
like that I'd be like super super out of
breath and have to like sit there and
catch my breath and kind of you know
catch my breath to be able to move
forwards what's the lowest moment was
there a moment where you're like I just
kids I just can't keep going yeah you
know it's so hard to pick one there may
be many many dark moments but you know
the one of the darkest moments for me
you know after the South Pole I arrived
at the South Pole on day 40 and as you
know there's been a lot of ups and downs
at that point I think I'm about you know
maybe thirty miles ahead of Lou at this
point or about a day ahead of day day
and a half ahead of him but I'm just you
know trying to find my rhythm and that
day actually for me ended up being this
beautiful day so I get to the South Pole
and it's a weird place because there's
actually a scientific research base
there there's there's other scientists
and things based out of there so it's
the one kind of like look at you know
the human world but I can't really touch
it if someone really
hands me a cup of coffee or a cookie you
know they're supported there are people
there and it's the middle of it when I
arrived I'm on Chilean time but they
stay on the New Zealand time the US base
does because they fly from Christchurch
and so it's this weird thing like it's
10:00 a.m. for me but it's like 2:00
a.m. the following day for them even
though even though we're they literally
the same location which is just like a
bizarre thing upon which part of the
planet you would like drive up on yeah
so a couple scientists actually did walk
out of the base and you know they had
been following along and kind of waved
and took a couple pictures but of course
they can't give me anything or anything
like that but I knew that you know and
that's that's understood in the polar
community that like you know you don't
have a lot of control over that but if
you take any support from them that's a
whole different thing and so not wanting
to be enough that I would be tempted but
not just to be in this environment for
very long I plan to only be there for 30
minutes so I arrived took a couple
pictures in front of the South Pole sign
and continued on and it was this
beautiful sunny day actually this kind
of calm day where I you know had these
just tears of joy rolling down my face
it was a bacchanal in my best moment so
it's kind of like oh like I made only 23
people I think have ever done solo
unsupported and unassisted from the
coast to the South Pole 23 24 in history
and so just doing that was like an
amazing accomplishment and all that all
the elevation gain is in your rearview
then right and so you're up on the
plateau so it's not like immediately
going downhill but yeah you're like on
the other side of this thing now you're
gonna hopefully be descending somewhere
it's like it's a big milestone and the
second half the the way that the route
was it's actually a further distance on
the front half was about six hundred and
some miles to get to the pole but only
three hundred and some to get to the
other ice shelf on the other side and so
like it's a big moment for me and I'm
like off kind of you know feeling good
about this and then the next day I just
get lit up in this storm and the next
seven or eight days they're like the
storms have lasted previous to this
about one or two days and then all of a
sudden this storm got seven you know six
days seven days eight days I find myself
you know kind of picking through this
sister Oogie you know day 48 eight days
in this battle with this storm the wind
hasn't been any linge lower than 40 50
mile-per-hour is just brutal conditions
and I find myself falling like really
bad so I actually fall on the ground hit
the ground super hard and I remember
this one moment I fall into this big
hole and my rope on my harness pulls
tight and then my sled starts sliding
toward
me and I'm in this kind of four-foot
hole and I see this sled like gonna like
maybe kind of fall down on top of me
it's like I'm looking where my leg is
but like I can't move it cuz the skis
are on the ground I'm like wow like and
it's like teetering it's like this sled
falls at me it's like a broken leg
broken ski in assists rooky storm and
then I looked down and my skin's have
ripped off the bottom of one of my skis
which is impossibly hard to get back on
in this storm and I've only gone for one
hour and so I'm like okay the only way
to get my skins back on is I set up my
tent so I think to myself okay like I
should set up my tent right now and then
like maybe regroup but I like can't just
waste the day because I am starting to
run or lower on food and certainly you
know trying to stay in the front of this
race and so I set up my tent and there's
this video clip of me where I didn't I
filmed a lot of this stuff my obviously
yeah filmed it all myself but I filmed a
lot through time when I'm looking in the
camera and I'm just going like I'm
sobbing and I'm like I'm not doing good
like I just want to give up like I'm
like so beat down and this and it was
just kind of in this moment you know two
things for me happen that moment to get
out of that headspace which is another
one of my favorite mantras it's a simple
and that a lot of us have which is this
- she'll pass you know remembering sort
of the impermanence of this moment but
also I had this satellite device that I
was pinging - the satellites every 10
minutes that people could track me in
real time that's how the New York Times
and family and friends and all these
school kids through a non-profit we're
following along and you know they see
that I've stopped and a friend of mine
Blake Brinker he he saw that I stopped
and was like wow somebody must not be
going like well for you like I was
checking in you could set these like
rudimentary text messages to the
satellite device and he sent the text
message and it's a passage from one of
my favorite books which is the alchemist
and he says he says remember the
allegory from The Alchemist that you're
being tested by all the lessons you have
to go through before finally achieving
the ultimate success and he goes don't
forget when passing the old the
alchemists of course is about the desert
but in order because its own kind of
desert and he says more often than not
people die of thirst when crossing the
desert a few minutes before seeing the
palm trees on the horizon and so it was
just this reminder of like yo like
you're in it like you are getting tested
right now but if you can manage to get
back out of this tent out of this tent
remember that this too shall pass
then you hopefully get to the other side
of this and
sure enough on that day it was tough but
you know just taking my tent up and down
in this storm takes an hour hour and a
half and I so I'd do that but instead of
getting my sleeping bag out I take my
tent down again fix my skins and get
back out and battle through this storm
and manage 20 miles that day which was a
pretty solid mileage for me on any given
day and I think to me that was both the
lowest moment but also a crux moment
where I'm being tested by all of these
things and it would have been there was
a million reasons to quit in that moment
at least maybe not quit the whole
project but quit and that moment be like
I'm falling I mean get hurt my sleds
gonna fall on me my skins are falling
off this storms less than a week like
I'm starting to get frostbite on my nose
and my cheeks like I'm beat up and I
still managed to you know with the
strength is sort of others and that
vibration from family and friends and
supporters is able to kind of draw some
strength and inspiration to keep going
that's incredible man how many days I
think it was like halfway you're about
halfway in when during your evening call
with Jen she's like I need you to be
around this between this time and this
time to make sure to answer the phone
Yeah right yes it was hilarious I see
where you go with this the this is one
of my favorite stories for this whole
adventure
so about so I actually spent most of the
time in silence I actually brought very
little with me via you know me at media
on my phone and stuff because I actually
was really curious about these flow
States and kind of exploring that in my
mind and didn't want to have kind of
this crutch of listening a bunch of
music or podcasts however sidenote to
tangent for the story I did listen to
the rich world podcast where she's quite
a few times out there it was actually
what a few podcasts that I had with you
and there was one moment I'll get back
the other story a second but there was
one moment in particular that was so
apropos which was your interview with
Desiree right after she won the Boston
Marathon and you know she you know she
her whole thing is keep showing up and
that was kind of her mantra and it was
like I was just at the right time that I
heard that like first of all like your
energy on this podcast is so just
resonant and positive and beautiful and
I just couldn't allow any kind of even
kind of negative voices in my head so
your voice to me this is a weird to say
to your Drive it's like it's so soothing
and calming I'm a big fan
and so that was amazing but that
conversation you had with her in
particular was this moment where I was
hitting that deep snow and like was like
why am i going so much slower and why
was this and I hear her whole story
about persevering and ultimately winning
the Boston Marathon her whatever 12th
year of being a professional and she's
like keep showing up just keep showing
up and so that that really hit me but
about around about this similar time and
I had been a lot of times in silence but
your podcast was uplifting and I also
needed just like a just an uplifting
moment so I put up one one album that I
brought with me was Paul Simon's
Graceland and I cranked that up on the
16th day I played it start to finish
about you know six or seven times and
it's one of those Alma being is just
looping it and it's one of those albums
you know my parents played at Tom when I
was a kid I think it came out in the
early 90s oz you know maybe seven eight
years old when that came out and it just
an album that I just absolutely love
like the drumming and the collaboration
is just a beautiful album and so I have
this like solo dance party by myself on
the 17th day just bumping Paul Simon's
Graceland and my evening post on
Instagram that night was like tough day
for me out here in the deep snow you
know I've been in the silence for a long
time but sided to just listen to
something I put that out there just like
no big deal and so day 35 a couple weeks
later as you mentioned Jenna says to me
and I'm in a getting pretty tired I'm up
on the polar plateau I'm about five days
out from the South Pole trying to stay
really focused on that you know getting
to that Waypoint and she says hey you
know I know your exhaust I know it's
been a long day you've already done all
that your steps and this is usually we'd
get on the phone I would go to sleep and
she goes I need you to call this one
other number and I'm like like why like
why and she's like I'm sure like just
trust me like call the number and I'm
like well it's just like just do it you
know I'm like fine and so I'm thinking
it's like a reporter as I'm really sure
what it is and I call this number and
this voice saying is this guy answer the
phone he's like Mike hi this is Colin
from Antarctica and he's like oh hello
hi this is Paul and I'm like Paul and
he's like yep Paul Simon Mel's like wait
what I was like 35 days in I haven't
talked to anyone I'm like my
hallucinating like am I actually sitting
in the middle of Antarctica much like
Paul Simon like if I completely lost my
mind but sure enough it was him and it
was you know of course I was just like
you know it's kind of stunned and
shocked by this conversation my you know
you know probably social skills were
pretty limited given how much solitude
I've been in but we
so having this conversation you know he
asked me about Antarctica some of the
bait how cold is it the basic questions
you might ask and then we end up having
this conversation which is like stuck
with me in such a deep way as I had kind
of like I said started to explore this
idea of being an artist more so than an
athlete and just like I said the serve
canvas being the endurance sports and so
we end up having this conversation about
like his album Graceland and how he
created it how he went to South Africa
during apartheid which was really
controversial but to get these beautiful
drum tracks from these local tribes and
the process of this creation and
ultimately for him was his art piece of
this beautiful masterpiece album that
has inspired millions of people through
dance and play and love and laughter and
all these things and we ended up talking
for you know 30 or 40 but it's a very
expensive satellite phone call from the
bottom of the world but it was just like
it hit me at just the right time to just
kind of keep me going and really connect
me back to this larger purpose which was
yes I was doing this yes I wanted to be
the first person as in a competitive
athlete and you know the curiosity about
challenging my body but really the
larger purpose of this entire project
was to put something into the world that
people would say like wow like I am paid
I face impossible goals in my life I
face challenges I face obstacles and yes
I might not want to walk across
Antarctica but we all have our
equivalent of an Antarctica or an
impossible challenge or an audacious
goal and we also have a million reasons
not to do this I can't I don't I want I
you know you know all these doubts and
these and so for me to put this it out
in the world in this way and connecting
with Paul and this sort of idea of
creation and art and this positivity
resonating from that it was just amazing
to have that conversation and also just
wildly surreal to be chatting with so
obviously somebody saw that post or he
saw it or it got to him yeah I barely
reached out Ghent somehow the wires got
connect yeah yeah so Jenna yeah they
reached out and said hey Paul I saw that
calling him and listening to his album
was there any way to connect with him
and whatnot and they connected the dots
and so Jenna knew who I was calling of
course when she gave me that phone
number why why she was like trust me
like a night Roshan it's like like she
wouldn't normally like she knows how
exhausted and you know she kept me
pretty protected I mean I was talking to
her and you know checked in with Adam
Skolnick New York Times a couple of
times it's not like I was even talking
to pretty much anybody on the phone yeah
no I'm not
was happening and even the conversations
with her although very uplifting at
times were like very like busy was like
okay like how much food is you would say
how much water how they get you know how
are you supply it so I was this you know
just like kind of safety checks more
than anything and of course there's an
emotional booth to be able to talk to my
incredible wife during that time is the
unsung hero in all of this yeah you're
always going out of your way to make
sure that she gets the credit that that
you know that's due her but you know the
more I kind of dive into this and learn
about you know how this whole thing went
down
I mean she's running a tight ship yeah
and you know you say unsung hopefully I
try to sing the praises as much as
possible and again that's not just you
know a shout out from a loving husband
to an amazing wife but as somebody who
is really the the backbone of this
entire operation from the strategy
around how to build it logistics the the
media and social media strategy the
nonprofit with the kids I mean she is a
incredibly savvy businesswoman this
artwork this creativity that we put into
the world does not exist without her
tremendous hardwork from her but then
you know she's balancing that with like
the emotions of a loving wife who's of
course worried about their spouse in
this challenging conditions and so she
somehow has this incredible way of being
able to balance both this strength of
this you know the savvy businesswoman
about the love and compassion towards me
as well as not holding me back and
encouraging and pushing me when I need
it you know one of my you know we've
gone through many you know fortunately
met you know 12 years ago met relatively
young and have gone through you know
very kind of waves of life together it's
amazing to be able to do this
collaboration full-time together you
know for years and years but you know
there's moments where you know she's
known how to push me I think I probably
told this story once on your podcast
before but you know being up on the
summit of Everest and coming back down
and I've you know I've got Denali left
to set the Explorer's grand-slam world
record and I call her from camp four in
the Death Zone I'm exhausted and I'm
like Jenna I'm exhausted you know I you
know someone at Everest you know if we
can get up to not only the next two
months I'm gonna set this record so give
me a couple days to rest whatever and
she goes she says to me she goes
actually uh I need you to put your boots
back on right now and I'm like excuse me
she's like yeah we've been doing some
calculating it just so happens if you
can get off Everest right now getting a
helicopter fly to Katmandu fly all the
way to enter Alaska and climbed Denali
not in three weeks but in three days you
can set not one but two World Records
like ready go so it's like
I say that story to illuminate you know
she's not only if she's like heck yeah
celebrating the accomplishments running
all these things in the background but
she's also like yeah you're at Camp for
never it's like put those boots back on
my mountain like we got stuff to keep
doing so I mean it's just it's just this
amazing partnership I feel so so so
blessed and this is you know you know
it's it's it's if anything it's 5050 us
if Noor so sometimes I feel like I've
got the easy job which is the linear
task of actually doing the physical
demands of this and she's just like you
know anything that you need exactly
she's juggling a hundred balls in orbit
and keeping them all in the air as well
as keeping me safe and alive and healthy
and well mentally physically so you know
Jenna Jenna is just such an
extraordinary person I'm so blessed it's
the only way this all happens well one
of the amazing things about this
expedition was that everybody could
share it online cuz every day you would
upload a photo and a post kind of
chronicling this in real-time which was
insane like that's one of the insanely
cool things about social media yeah no
problems with it but like it was amazing
to like everyday like okay where's Colin
how's he doing where is he and you would
like have these photos so I have so many
questions yeah like first of all like
how does it even work like he's how is
he even taking pictures and then how are
those pictures getting from where he is
to ending up on Instagram like how is he
writing these posts like what is the
backstory there yeah so you know Jenna
and I really made this commitment to
share these stories in real time you
know as much as I admire the the polar
explorers the explorers of decades or
centuries ago and sort of the purity of
that of going off into this great
unknown for several years at times
sometimes and coming back and sharing
this story we of course live in this
world but the technology exists with
some some crazy loopholes to do it in
Antarctica but where you can share these
stories in real time and I think the
real like I said the passion for me is
this resonance of positivity with other
people you know I'm not so interested in
being the athlete in the arena of people
watching me like oh good job you set
another world record but it's more so
like whoa like I get these tons of
messages now that just like you know
mean the world to me where people write
to me on Instagram they go like I heard
your story and I'm a single mother you
know dealing with this hard thing in my
life like thank you for encouraging me
to keep putting one foot
the other in my life for that and so we
really have this commitment to sharing
these stories in real time as much as
possible we started that a couple years
ago I was actually the first person in
history to snapchat from the summit of
Mount Everest back in 2016 you know you
know some fun things we've done there
but that you know the how and why you
know that's the why the how is you know
we I carry this little satellite modem
with me you know like I said no extra
pair of underwear what we committed to
you know carrying the weight for this
and it's solar powered so in Antarctica
I've got 24 hours of daylight and so one
of the benefits of that of course is I
have these small solar panels that can
charge your electronics but it's not
really that straightforward and simple
it's not like I'm like browsing
Instagram or I had like a proper
internet connection it takes me about
sometimes an hour between 30 minutes an
hour to upload one single image to
genna's inbox in like relatively low res
and then she reposts it but all the
words everything I wrote were mine and
so at the end of every single day there
were times when I didn't necessarily
want to put you know I was just like
exhausted with all the things I was
doing I just wanted to go to sleep but I
had made this commitment to really share
this story and I knew that there were
you know thirty thousand school kids on
six continents following along and
tuning on you know so you know hundreds
of thousands of people I guess
ultimately millions of people tuning in
and following this thing which was you
know incredibly humbling to realize and
I just be committed to sharing it like
exactly how it was happening like the
good days were great that the tough days
were tough that things going in my mind
the doubt the fears the ups and downs
and so I would just sit down and it was
actually in the end a beautiful process
of a moment to reflect on the end of
each day and kind of put it to words and
it's nice you know I've been an avid
journaler throughout my life but it's
nice to be able to look back on those
posts and being like oh like this is how
it's feeling but the photos it's
hilarious if you were following my
Instagram feed during this time almost
every day I didn't of course I didn't
know this because I couldn't see the
comments I couldn't see Instagram you
know I was just put I would write a text
email and send this via the satellite
even know like I would leave comments
thinking like well maybe he does have a
an iPhone that connects and he can
actually be on this planet from time to
time you know Jenna would send me like
oh you know actually she told me he
would comment a couple of times which is
super cool and in various though she
passed some comments on but no I can't
open Instagram like an open anything but
um you know she's taking the image and
taking the text right right and this
email and post putting them together but
it was funny she was like she was
like literally every single day like 10
people comment like well you're not
really alone because you've got this
camera crew out there obviously taking
these photos of you and so it's
hilarious because of course that is not
the case I took all the photos of myself
and have a GoPro or what were you doing
yeah so what's really tough when it's
that cold is that cameras the battery
dies like in like 30 seconds and also we
should take your gloves off and you have
like bare hands on like electronics like
your fingers can get frost bit like
pretty quickly and so it was challenging
to take all those images though it's
funny now to watch back from the video
footage because you know we've cut it
into some beautiful piece of me like
walking off into the distance in
Antarctica whatever but of course the
video continues and I turn around and
come back camera it's not as glamorous
but yeah the one thing that worked
really well for me to get a lot of those
shots a lot of them are stills I mean I
could on I could only share stills from
an article ii couldn't send video files
but the videos we've now you know
uploaded now but i use the gopro mostly
and i would let it run and now they will
be like it take a single frames frame
for screenshot screenshot of a video
exactly and so that worked the best
because it was really i mean was almost
impossible to capture like motion turn
it up and walk by yeah and I had a
little tripod with me I'd like set it up
and walk by and be like oh like that one
frame is where I'm setting up my tent
and I want to like show that or I want
to like show this crazy storm or this
you know I did my best you know with
what I had to cram yeah things are like
a whole thing for the entire purpose no
not at all but it was a fun it was
amazing like you said I think that I I
have the same feeling about social media
which is there's a lot of things wrong
with it and we think are all guilty at
times or being sucked into that world
and I try to not get my brain too foggy
with that but it's also incredible to be
able to actually like in real time share
this journey and what was amazing for me
and I didn't really realize at the time
again Jenna was kept me in a pretty
productive bubble which was necessary to
the high performance element of this but
the amount of people that started
following along and amount of people
that were interested and not of people
commenting the amount of people you know
again sending these messages of
positivity about their own lives or
overcoming their obstacles fears they're
going through it definitely became
something that I'm proud of in that way
it's weird to say although I think maybe
on your podcast is one place where I
don't sound like a weirdo saying this
but I really started to feel this just
resonant positivity back you know from
the universe from this of me kind of
putting this out in the world but all
the sudden like I said you know there
was moments when you know either Jenna
or close friend or something would send
me something but more than anything is
this kind of built in the energy around
this bill I felt like not alone I felt
like there was just this like
groundswell of positive energy
reverberating into you know both
directions and I was very viscerally
connected to that and that was a
beautiful thing I don't know if that's
from you know not specifically from
Instagram or whatnot but from the amount
of people you know like you know
cheering me on saying encourage things
as well as kind of having that go in a
two-way direction of me hopefully
encouraging others well that low-grade
aerobic output matched with solitude and
then being in a place where there's no
humans around for as far as you can see
and zero distractions if that's not
going to contribute to a some level of
flow state and be some kind of self
reflection and you know spiritual
awakening yeah I don't know what's gonna
do ya know I mean it was it was it was
it was beautiful I mean no meditation is
something that's been a big part of my
life for several years thing in 2011 was
the first time I did a 10-day Vipassana
you know 10 day silent no reading have
you done one of those before yeah like
it seems like every single guest is like
I was just up at Jack Dorsey's haha
telling me about his latest 10 day yeah
no retreat
GameChanger highly recommend you know
that you know people ask me like I'm
never gonna panic I'm nervous I'm like
if you wanna do something that has like
profound and deep impact 10-david pasta
I mean it's it's free to go it's just a
commitment of your body and spirit of
mind and it's really really beautiful
and I've done that several times that
certainly helped prepare me for the
solitude in some some regard but this 54
days was just like the next like the
deepest deepest layer of the ultra Bosna
and it was incredible I mean it was
incredible to feel that it was
incredible to actually feel not alone
most of the time and and it did connect
me to you know whatever you want to call
that the universe the vibration of the
planet I definitely felt really
connected in that way and that was
really profound but also you know I
wrote down you know four or five you
know lessons right
I got back I've always been able to
unpack more of this now but you know top
of mind when I finished was really about
like love this work this this repetition
of infinite love infinite love infinite
love this ability that we I think we all
have as humans to love infinitely to
love to love our neighbors to love our
family and friends but really to
actually put that positivity in the
residence of love into the universe and
how much that can reflect back when we
do so you know that was really clear to
me in this moment and all these sort of
lessons about of course this deep
connection with Jenna and this sort of
emotional journey that we were able to
go on together was beautiful but also
connected me back to you know family and
friends and memories that I had lost
from the past that I kind of came up in
these beautiful moments of childhood
with my sister and my mother are kind of
reliving these moments that kind of
connected me back you know not that I'm
disconnected from my family but on a
deeper level of you know family and
friendship and really kind of the
essence of all of this was how much as
humans of course I'm all alone in this
from you know pontificating about but
I'm thinking about the importance of
community the importance that we all
have to lean in to love one another to
really be compassionate to help to
uplift and support one another and how
much stronger we can be when there's
that you know not this finite level of
love but this infinite love that we can
share with one another and what that can
really create in this universe was was
absolutely spectacular to feel that and
be so viscerally connected to that at
the end of this journey and what does it
taught you about not only your own
capabilities but about human
capabilities in general and and and
potential you know I feel like I
scratched the surface of this you know
11 years ago and we've talked about this
before but when I was severely burning
this fire in Thailand I was told I would
never walk normally and then I recover
from that through the guidance of my
mother's love and positivity ultimately
yeah and I'm gonna interrupt you really
quickly here just to share one
reflection on that we have talked about
that and I'm well aware of that story
from their life but this is how weird
memory works yeah in my mind I had this
sense that that had happened way earlier
in your life than it actually had and
when I serve realized like oh wait that
was 2008 like that wasn't that long ago
that dude that was only 10 years ago
yeah exactly so yeah I was I had been a
collegiate swimmer before that mean kind
of gone through a big chapter of my life
and
yeah it was you know took a surfboard in
a backpack and scraped together some
pennies after college to go travel the
world and I met Jenna at the very
beginning of that trip so that was a net
positive for that who loved him who
became of course the most important
person in my life but not long after
that I found myself in rural Thailand
with the kerosene flaming rope wrapped
around my legs my body lit on fire and
I'm having to dive into the ocean to
extinguish the flames I saved my life
but not before my legs were severely
burnt and spent several months in this
high hospital being told I would never
walk again normally and in that moment
my mother came she arrived about the
fourth or fifth day and kind of comes to
my bedside and she says like Collin like
visualize your future like visualized
yourself you know being whatever you
want to be you know your life's not over
and I was just in this deep tragic you
know place in my mind and my body and my
spirit and I closed my eyes kind of
trying to you know placate my mother in
some regard and I pictured myself
crossing the line of a triathlon which
is not something I'd ever done and so I
won't get into the whole story but the
you know the next 18 months were kind of
learning from that lesson and keeping
this sort of fixed goal my mind of
racing this triathlon and ultimately you
know competing in the Chicago triathlon
as an amateur and winning my first you
know ever trap one of my first go at it
which was crazy a crazy moment but the
reason I bring that story up I mean it's
important inflection point in my life
which is you know in that moment I
started to feel I wasn't like wow like
I'm so amazing like I I'm so blessed and
so good that sounds like wow like as
humans I believe we all have these
reservoirs of untapped potential inside
of us and can achieve these
extraordinary things when we shift our
mindset for the positive when we're
supported by this loving community of
infinite love and compassion and
positivity like wow like how
extraordinary is that and so that was my
first kind of lesson towards that but I
was you know 20 to 23 years old and I'm
kind of the beginning of this journey
which has been the last you know decade
of my life in this chapter in Antarctica
certainly not the last chapter of my
life but the most recent chapter of my
life is Antarctica and to connect to
that on such an even even you know 10x
or 100x deeper level which is like wow
like what look at what we are capable of
myself I mean people keep coming back
you know I do these interviews and
things and people want to say like Colin
like are you superhuman and I'm like
yeah I'm superhuman and so are you like
so are all of us but just
I think it just happens how we flex this
muscle between our ears is six inches
between our ears like what we can do
with their minds is extraordinary and
how we can all be connected and
uplifting each other in that sense and
so for me and an article the lessons
learned were yes about my own potential
but really were resonant you know across
humanity of what we are all capable when
we set our minds things and again I
don't think the necessary anyone wants
to walk across an article so
unsupportive no Nate I don't blame you
for not wanting to do that but like we
have dreams we have goals and it's so
easy to get in our own ways of stopping
the progress towards that and like when
I started this whole thing like like I
said you know Jenna and I had like no
money we have like a whiteboard on our
wall every reason not to do this and
like you should be like yeah like go get
a real job like grow up like do
something we're like no like what can we
do to have positive impact let's start a
non-profit like let's dare to dream
greatly and like we started out by like
taking out our Mac laptops being like
well if we want people on social media
to do this we better know about
marketing I had like 200 Instagram
followers like my parents and my close
friends and we're googling like Google
what's the difference between marketing
and PR like we're basic of all basic
questions you know but I just got the
metrics back on this last project and we
did you know as of now it's 1.8 billion
media impressions and Counting and I
don't say that because like I care about
having like my name in like the press
but because of that we've created this
platform this ability to share these
stories about inspiration positivity
love
nutrition health all the things that I'm
passionate about and I know from you
from having this podcast itself so a
blessing for you to be able to you know
have this voice not because like you
want to be rich roll this like famous
guy but because you have this
opportunity to share with the world and
the resonant positivity that you can put
in the world from that as incredibly
humbling and meaningful and I applaud
you for it I mean you know lasting
impact that's the juice right so what is
the what is the lasting impact that that
you know what is the impact that you
want this adventure and everything that
you're doing going forward to have like
what is the change that you want to see
in the world yeah you know I think that
when I've really tried to drill down to
this I you know I mentioned this before
like sort of this athlete and arena and
I'm a by the way I'm a massive sports
fan like I'm you know I like watching
sports as throughout my life but I think
that our sort of knowledge or interest
in sports in general not always the case
I think like the NBC Olympic coverage is
a great
example of not doing this but oftentimes
the sports are like winning losing like
this sort of like the zero-sum game of
like cheering for your team we're
rooting against the enemy or something
like that but you know for me and doing
this it's not so much about that at all
it's about tapping into these sort of
universal truths that we all face and
encounter which is like facing obstacles
stepping outside of our comfort zone to
grow and being an example of those
lessons and showing you know showing all
the flaws like I'm not sitting here
going like yep I stepped off the plane I
knew I could beat Lou he was not you
know it's like no like I like had this
huge daunting task of crossing
Antarctica oh and by the way like the
most experienced boats poor in the world
it's also out there beside me but I was
willing to like give it a shot which is
I think emblematic of someone starting a
small business everyone going like oh
but like why wouldn't Google or Facebook
just like do the same thing why would
you start with that tech idea like
that's never gonna work or you know the
person that's like starting a family or
has lost a loved one and like just
figuring out how to get on through life
and so hopefully like by sharing my
story as authentically and really as I
can with all the ups and downs and the
struggles and the warts and the
successes that people can take from that
in their own life's what they will and
really paint their own masterpieces
mm-hmm beautiful man
and you're you're working on a book I am
I am working on a book that's really
exciting
you know that's of course fun to be able
to you know be offered that platform to
be able to do that I know you you've sat
and done that yourself so I'm cutting my
teeth on my first book but you know
hoping to have that out within the next
year or so but it's been really excited
to begin to dive into that process
really it's a fun process for me you
know I've been fortunate to be able to
share this story I am you know I do a
lot of no public speaking and things
like that but to be able to sit and this
one reasons I love doing podcast
interviews because it's like one thing
like you know you've been on these short
TV segments before it's like three
minutes like say your thing real quick
like I'm rich roll-y vegan traffic
whatever it is it like Arctica was it
cold yeah yeah so it's like this like
weird thing and why I love podcasting of
course is the you know I love
storytelling and the ability to you know
go deep and get real and it seems like
at least I'm still kind of in the early
stages of this process but it's forcing
me to like get real about a longer form
story I mean of course it's I'm from
or a thousand-page book but even 300
pages or whatever gives you the
opportunity to really you know dive into
different moments of times and
illuminate different you know things and
it's been really I think nice with
Antarctica with this project
specifically of course I think the the
book will it's gonna be memoir mostly
with you know what's gonna cover in
article of course but it's also going to
talk about other elements of my life and
things and you know it gives me a sense
to really reflect on the stories even
the ones that don't necessarily make it
into the book let's say it's amazing to
go back through my journals from being a
young kid and seeing sort of these
pivotal moments or maybe moments that I
forgot or you know really kind of go
back through antarctica day8 earn the
page on our life so often it's easy to
be like oh yeah yeah sure i did that you
know for you like oh yeah I erased
Ultraman II you know that was and
whatever we need to go back and you read
those journals or you're going up on
stage and you're sharing your story your
story starts to tell you what it is yes
there's a there's an aspect of
self-discovery and self exploration
with that that I think leads to personal
growth if done right 100% and I think
that it's fun for me I've been back you
know from Antarctica for two months and
you know yeah it's sitting down with you
is always amazing because I feel like I
should like oh you money at the end of
this because it's like this cathartic
giving you like five speeches of weep
down like like he's gonna tell the story
again you're all animated and lit up so
you know like a but I'm wondering like
is it you know you it's that thing where
it's like if you're doing it too much
like when does it start to become rote
and none less not coming from that heart
place and I think that's what's
beautiful about at least the moment I
mean I can't you know I can't project
forward ten years or something like that
but at least like right in this moment
is like I'm still learning things like
I'm humbled that people want me on
stages right now and I'm sharing this
story and I share it as well as I
possibly can and I think that there's
some great you know great nuggets and
take homes and all those things it's a
great story in that sense but I'm still
learning from it like I'm still
unpacking the lessons from that and I
think that that's a amazing thing to
have a genuine curiosity about where
you've come to also dictate where you're
going and to really sit in that moment
of reflection I mentioned real briefly
before about this idea of memories but
you know I had long since thought
certain memories of mine were gone from
childhood or things like that but when I
had the time to sit still and Antarctica
I mean not physically sit still with the
stillness in my mind you know I found
this incredible you know ability to go
back and catalog these memories not like
of epic things that happened in but also
some of the like the mundane moments of
you know driving to school as a kid with
my sister or things like that what we
were singing listening to on the radio
my first swim race ever and not like oh
yeah I have my first one we're afraid I
was wrong as five years olds like I'm
diving into the pool and I can see my
mother on the other side and the wind's
blowing and she's wearing an orange
shirt and I'm you know like the whole
thing is playing out in this rich and
vivid detail and so it's exciting for me
to be going back and reflecting in my
life not knowing like gosh I need to
like remind myself of what happened but
go like actually like it's in there like
I'm a product of all of these things
that happened we all are a product of
these memories whether we can recall
them quickly in our social media and
instant gratification type of world that
we live and it's a little bit harder but
when you take that stillness and that
pause and that's why these what pasta
meditations have been beautiful for me
as well as these moments of really deep
reflection to you know reflect on
mistakes I've made and you know things
that I want to change going forward and
ultimately grow yeah what do you is
there anything that that like the media
is getting wrong or where you feel like
you've been misunderstood in this whole
journey um you know not really um I
think actually a a Lewis house and I
were talking about this last week and I
love what he says I'm not gonna get his
perfect quote right he's like pretty
artistic but something along the lines
of like he goes like you ever write a
negative review like on like Yelp or
something like that and I'm like no like
why would I ever sit back and just kind
of this idea that like no matter what
you do there's gonna be like that 1% of
like well why would you do this or you
know people will say like oh it must
have been easy for you because you must
have like so much money and I'm like I
actually grew up like quite poor we're
like you know like oh but like you have
this like Ivy League education was like
cuz I worked really hard as a swimmer
when I was a kid and was like offered
that opportunity to have a great
education but like based on like hard
work not putting some like pedigreed
like background you know it's like
there's certain things that can people
can pull but you know when people you
know kind of reflect that way I try to
just reflect back like the positive and
just like hey like this is my
like I'm out here doing my very best and
you know hoping to move forwards that so
there's like little tiny things like
that well there's always gonna be
grousing yeah you know there's a little
bit I mean there's some there's a little
controversy over Borge oh yeah right
yeah so he's the guy who in 1996
traversed Antarctica he actually went
quite a bit further on a totally
different route but there was some wind
aided with a sail or something like that
so there's there's certain people out
there who are you know basically like
what borsch did it first right yeah so I
mean it's interesting you know that that
whole piece of its been just kind of not
not bizarre but just interesting to me
because before I even launched my
project when I kind of put my website up
like hey I'm doing this project it's
called the impossible first I'm gonna
try to be the first person across solo
unsupported and unaided which has been
something people multiple people have
tried before me I didn't just like
create this rapid thin air and I said
you know there's been like five
expeditions that I want to highlight
that have been like exceptionally
inspirational to me and like the top one
on this on my website before I take any
single step in Antarctica it's like what
board Gosselin did in 1996 and I might
get his name Bora Bora Iceland I think
is it's Norwegian you know this is what
he did in 1996-1997 like I explicitly
called it out as one of the expeditions
that's been most inspirational to me
what he did then was he crossed not only
the landmass of Antarctica but also the
entirety of the ice sheets of the frozen
ocean that I mentioned he crossed that
and he was able to do so using kites and
so you know he oftentimes went you know
there's a lot written on this New York
Times actually covered it there's lots
of quotes about him and he used these
parasails that actually took him
sometimes 150 200 miles per day he did
that entire crossing almost twice the
distance that I went in almost the exact
amount of time and he's been you know
he's on the record quoting like oh it'd
be impossible to cross both ice sheets
as well just man hauling unsupported but
in his sense he's like but I was the
first person to cross Antarctica solo
and I'm like you absolutely were like
these are just apples and oranges I was
purely man hauling crossing the landmass
and you were using kite and wind aid by
the way that's extraordinary what you
accomplished I'm not trying to take away
anything from that like I said to me
it's just apples and oranges and again
without even knowing that there was any
sort of you know quote-unquote
controversy which to me is like pretty
minimal anyways but you know there was
some chatter about that the day after I
finished my project I'd have finished on
December 26 and I posted the Instagram
of you know I finished you know wow what
a day or something like that and then
the following day again not knowing
anything about controversy I was in my
own little bubble just writing from my
tent whatever popped in my mind and I
wrote this post on December 27th that's
called standing on the shoulders of
giants and it was like wow like it's
amazing to step into the history books
and do this you know this world first
that no one had done before but none of
this happens without all the other
pioneering explorers and the amazing
things they'd done and I called out
Borghi owsla and I called out Felicity
Ashton who's a woman who did a supported
but solo crossing of Antarctica on a
very similar route which was amazing so
she had read two recent lives of food
and just calling out these other
explorers that have been inspirational
to me so for me the only way that I
could you know kind of reflect on that
which is like it's not a controversy in
my mind like I've been nothing but very
clear that Burgos and what he did was
inspirational and incredible
he used a kite I didn't like he went
further I went a shorter distance but
man hauled only crossed the landmass he
crossed the ice sheets I mean they're
both like I mean it's like splitting
hairs over like you know is like the
slam dunk at the all-star game in 96
when Jordan did it cooler than like when
this uh you know it's like it's just
like they're awesome like we can't we
all just like celebrate these these
moments of achievement that are unique
and interesting in their own way so yeah
I gotcha
after doing this whole thing it must
have been freaky the first time you were
back on the mainland and it was actually
it got dark at night yes yes yeah I mean
that was that was absolutely bizarre
this 24 hours of daylight out there I
actually got quite accustomed to it and
used to it but you could I could easily
see how people lose their minds with
that yes yes I mean I had to have you
know an eye mask over my eyes and try to
like your body is just like not adapted
to doing that the one the one cool
benefit which you haven't we hadn't
spoke about yet but was that final push
that I made yeah sorry about that so you
do this crazy 32 hour push to finish
yeah so I woke up on Christmas Day
actually and I'm step
seven miles away from the finish and I
think oh you know I've been averaging
about 10 to 12 or sorry about 15 to 16
miles per day average throughout the
entire project but my sled was lighter
and I was beginning to go downhill a
little bit and I was like oh maybe I
could do about 25 miles per day that's
probably three more days and I could
finish this thing but for me like my
guard is still way up like Henry Worsley
you know fell ill hundred miles from the
finish line it's like this thing isn't
done until it's done
and I wake up that morning on Christmas
morning and I just tap in to this this
deep flow state and your question was
about you know how do people getting
things wrong in the media I don't think
they're getting things wrong but there's
this this state that I'm trying to
describe of this sort of deep flow state
I think you know athletes other high
performers you know musicians things
have felt that but sometimes we were
like what do you like what is this like
crazy like weird abstraction that you're
talking about but you know for me it's
just waking up and having just this
moment of like true like confidence and
clarity of this like I start calculating
my head I'm like okay like people have
run ultra marathons before like the
sun's never gonna set like could I just
do 32 hours straight or 30-some hours
straight to finish this thing and one go
and it seemed crazy other than the fact
that even though my body was so
exhausted I was running low on food but
I had just enough to kind of you know
push through a couple more you know a
couple more days and I just locked in to
this place in my mind that was just like
calm and collected and I was gonna
complete silence and really just taking
in the moment it was this beautiful
moment where I felt like all of the
experiences of my entire life were
stacking that you know five-year-old kid
jumping into the swimming pool that you
know my burn accident in the lessons for
that family relationships love
heartbreak like just all of the moments
a meditation practice the training with
Mike like all of these things were
stacking this way that I finally
eventually reached this this moment of
just utter and complete calm and focus
so I I go on through the day you know 10
hours 15 hours 18 hours and that's the
longest I've ever gone and finally this
massive storm blows up there's actually
this huge ground blizzard comes out of
nowhere wind kicks up because it had
been a calm nice day when I sort of got
this idea in my mind I pushed through
and I get stuck in this crazy storm and
it's now midnight and which means it's
7:00 it's midnight Chilean time the
times when I stayed on but it's still 24
hours daylight but at 7 p.m. back home
in Oregon
it's Christmas Day and so my family's
been tracking this satellite tracker
throughout the day and they're like he
didn't stop after 12 hours didn't soften
for 13 hours like 18 hours so I call
home after 18 hours because what happens
is I actually ran out of water and the
only way for me to get more water in the
middle of this storm was to set up my
tent and light my stove inside of my
tent so I set up my tent
get inside call home and it's Christmas
dinner my families at Christmas oh my
Jenna puts a phone on speaker and it's
like my mother my sisters you know Jenna
these incredibly strong women that have
like supported me throughout my five
five older sisters so I just live in the
been been raised by an incredible
incredible people and women particularly
in this case and you know they get on
the phone they're like you did 47 miles
like this your best day ever you're
gonna finish tomorrow or the next day
like incredible and I was like actually
like I'm gonna keep going
and they're like wait what and I was
like I'm in this you know this this
really focused state like I know I can
do it and it's just in that moment we
talked about sort of Jenna pushing me to
put those boots back on before or she
when she describes this moment you know
she's actually videotaped all of our
conversations on on her end so we could
reflect on them afterward just kind of a
video diary and she was like I just
heard it in your voice like I've seen
you hyper form I've seen you broken down
she was like there was something in your
voice you sounded stronger on day 53
then you had felt sounded the entire
time and so they just said to me like
all right but they just said like oh the
weather must be really good and I was
like actually it's like some of the
worst of the whole project but I'm gonna
go back out there but even though it was
storming and raging outside of my tent I
had this inner calm that made all the
difference so I got outside my tent took
my tent back down after boiling the
water and made it another 12 hours
ultimately a 32-hour and 77 mile
continuous push to finish it up yeah and
as much as Jenna is there to push you
and say put your boots on and keep going
she's also there to put the brakes on
exactly if if you know she gets the
sense that this is gonna be unsafe yeah
because people do lose their minds out
there yes and get ahead of themselves
and that's ultimately how people die
yeah my sister Caitlin has she had said
to me and she was amazing she actually
built all that mapping stuff if you ever
went to the live tracker during the
project she built all that and
she she had actually said to me a few
days before that she's like I think
you're gonna finish this thing and it
looks like you have a margin of error
that you're ahead of loose you'll finish
first unless you do something stupid
like just go continuously so long that
you tell yourself it's like also in the
back of my mind like but it was it was
weird it's hard to again I'm still
there's one things I'm still trying to
reflect on and try to hopefully I'll put
it more articulate in to articulate in
two words in in book form but to
describe that state that state of just
like just knowing and calm and feeling
again that sort of resonant positivity
from the universe the people cheering me
on the fact that it was you know
Christmas I think on that day and people
were gathered and celebrating with their
family and their loved ones there was
just something about this sort of magic
moment that all came to pass of this all
of these moments stacking in a beautiful
way that allowed me to you know push
through 77 miles straight in 32 hours to
get to the finish line and it was for me
a beautiful way as someone who's curious
about exploring the the limits that we
all have inside of us to kind of break
through a perceived limit in my own life
and show that I had even more in the
tank at the end and I really even
thought possible
what's next what's next no one ever has
to be that yeah what's next yeah you got
to go you got to top it Yeah right you
know I think that it's a dangerous game
in this world to try to be always
one-upping oneself you know it's been
it's been a blessing to you know have
these these World Records and this this
world first and things that I've done
but alright as somebody in fairness
because you've gone from one thing to
the next to the next to the next about
like even a breather of between yes this
is like the first break you've taken yes
it's only because you're in like media
demand if the phone wasn't ringing you
know you know I have you know I have
some ideas of course in the back of my
mind
fluttering about about other expeditions
and things but it is really like I said
the storytelling and the sharing of this
is is humbling that people want to hear
this story and it's amazing to have a
moment to do that and certainly you know
diving into a book and things like that
as you know like require a dedicated
focus and that and so it's nice and also
in a moment when I need to recover my
body a bit to have
more of a still activity to do you know
I'm I turned 34 next week so I'm 33
right now there's you know there's a
long life ahead of me of adventures and
explorations and all sorts of different
things but I also like I said I don't I
don't um you know and maybe this is why
there's controversies with the likes of
the burger osun's or whatever is that
you know I don't necessarily think of
myself as this endemic outdoor athlete
you know you know I was doing triathlon
I loved professional triathlon by the
necessaries think of myself as a
triathlon insider as well I think
there's going to be many chapters in my
life where I can express myself through
physical demands through you know
business through interpersonal
relationships and so what's next is
hopefully a full and complete life and
things that bring me joy and that I can
reflect that back out into the world
well this canvas that you're painting
this art expression that is the
manifestation of your expeditions in the
way you're living your life is a
beautiful thing man
so I salute you I'm so proud and honored
to be your friend and it was really cool
to see you get out there and accomplish
that but I think what touches me more
than anything is the way that you're now
out there really trying to inspire
people and and help them redefine their
own sense of potential and frame new
stories around ultimately you know what
we're all capable of absolutely yeah
thank you so much for having me it's a
blessing out I have to say this one last
thing which is eyes like I said I didn't
listen to much out there but I did
listen to my fair share of rich world
podcast and I appreciated that generally
generally you know I sometimes maybe I
shouldn't say this out loud but I would
pass through the ads from time to time
yeah and you're the only one I had them
all memorized you do that me undies
commercial and I'm like I have one pair
of underwear it's wouldn't be nice to
have some me undies right now and like
your final color barriers yeah I had it
all the words down your foes closing
credits and music by analemma and the
whole thing I wish I could record the
outro but I had it all in my house come
in and do it for me
honestly music by Jason camiolo well
thanks for that man and come back
anytime man when the books when the book
comes out come back share with me we
love that and we'll keep this
conversation wrong absolutely thank you
my friend all right peace so you're
super easy guy to find at Collin Oh
Brady yeah Instagram is probably the
best place but Collin Oh Brady calm is
that website that's ray and I'm sure if
you're doing any speaking engagements
that are open to the public they'll be
up on your website yeah Collin Abreu
comms got everything about my speaking
at Collin Brady on Instagram I love
hearing from people I read all my DM
just reach out say hello this community
you've built is such extraordinary
people and when I got going to my first
project as one of the first early
supporters was your podcast listeners so
have such so much love and compassion
for this community it's just the perfect
vibration and resonance with me so all
the love to everyone out there and
thanks for all the support over the
years
appreciate that yes love my friend peace
plants and Collin bars yeah
[Music]